When does fast delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without its grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that, actually, they will stay for dinner. Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer. So download the app and get delivery in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus, enjoy zero dollar delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply.
什么时候最需要Instacart的极速配送服务？当你的招牌芥末土豆沙拉没有了颗粒芥末就不再是那个味道时。当烧烤架已经点燃却发现没有什么可烤时。当公公婆婆突然决定今晚要在家里吃晚饭时。今年夏天，Instacart为你包办了所有的生鲜百货。只需下载应用程序，即可享受最快60分钟送达服务。此外，前三笔订单还可享受免配送费优惠。服务费、不适用范围及条款适用。
Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
Instacart，超值交付的生鲜杂货。我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极办公室重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妹。
Hello everyone. Hi you guys. We are really excited about this week's episode. It's kind of special. It really is. We got to interview Mike Schur. You guys know he played Moe's on the show. He was also one of our original writers. We got to interview Mike Schur. You guys know he played Moe's on the show. He was also one of our original writers. We got to interview him and it was awesome. It was delicious. We loved it. We re-listened to it and we're like, this needs to be a whole episode. Yeah. We just had so much to talk with him about. But first, we're still going to give you fast facts. Always fast facts, guys. You know. Always fast facts. Oh my gosh. Jen, I feel like you're going to give you fast facts. Always fast facts, guys. You know. Always fast facts.
大家好。你们好呀。我们对这周的节目感到非常兴奋。这期节目有点特别。确实如此。我们采访了迈克·舒尔。大家都知道他在剧中饰演莫斯。他也是我们的原创编剧之一。我们采访了迈克·舒尔。大家都知道他在剧中饰演莫斯。他也是我们的原创编剧之一。我们采访了他，感觉太棒了。太精彩了。我们非常喜欢。我们重听了一遍，觉得这必须成为一整期节目。是的。我们有太多关于他的话题想聊了。但首先，我们还是要为你带来快讯。永远都有快讯，伙计们。你们懂得。永远都有快讯。哦，天哪。珍娜，我觉得你以后……
Oh my gosh. Jen, I feel like you're going to be in your eighties and you're going to be sitting in a corner mumbling like, fast facts, fast facts, fast facts. And they'll be like, what's grandma talking about? Oh, she used to do this thing called fast facts. Well, these are Mike's sure fast facts. Fast fact number one, Mike was on the writing staff from season one through season four. He wrote 10 episodes and here's what they were.
哦，天哪。珍娜，我觉得你到八十岁时，还会坐在角落里喃喃自语，说什么快讯，快讯，快讯。然后大家会问，奶奶在嘀咕什么呢？哦，她以前做过一个叫快讯的节目。好吧，这些是迈克的快讯。快讯第一条，迈克从第一季到第四季都在编剧团队。他写了10集剧本，以下是剧本列表：
The Alliance, Office Olympics, Christmas Party, Valentine's Day. That was one of our hidden gems in our re-listen, branch closing, traveling salesmen, the return, the negotiation, the job, that's the one where Jim comes in and asks Pam on a date at the end. I know. And Dunder Mifflin infinity. You know, Mike told me the negotiation was his favorite Angela Martin episode. Oh, really? She's like getting titillated by hearing people recount the Jim and Roy scuffle.
《联盟》、《办公室奥运会》、《圣诞派对》、《情人节》。这是我们在重温时发现的隐藏珍品之一、《分公司倒闭》、《旅行推销员》、《回归》、《谈判》、《工作》，就是吉姆进来在结尾约帕姆出去的那一集。我懂的。还有《邓德·米夫林无限公司》。你知道的，迈克告诉我，《谈判》是他最喜欢的安吉拉·马丁单集。哦，真的吗？她听到别人复述吉姆和罗伊的争执时，好像觉得很刺激。
Oh, yes. Yes. Yeah. He said that was his favorite episode to write for my character. I felt like he just liked writing for your character a lot. Your character always had great moments in his episodes. They did. I loved it when Mike was assigned an episode.
哦，是的。是的。是的。他说这是他为我的角色写得最喜欢的一集。我觉得他真的很喜欢为你写剧本。你的角色在他的剧本里总是表现得很精彩。确实如此。我很喜欢迈克分到剧本的时候。
Well Mike also wrote the accountants webisodes with Paul Lieberstein. He played Moe's in 13 episodes of the show starting in season two. He talks a lot about playing Moe's in our interview. It's very fun. It is. His love-hate relationship with Moe's. Well, here is fast fact number two. I'm going to talk to you about shows he's created.
嗯，迈克还和保罗·利伯斯坦一起创作了《会计师》网络剧。从第二季开始，他在13集中饰演了莫斯。他在采访中聊了很多关于饰演莫斯的经历。非常有趣。确实如此。他对莫斯又爱又恨的关系。好了，这是快讯第二条。我要和大家聊聊他创作的节目。
I think you guys know the show that he started on SNL. He was there for six seasons. During his time on SNL, he produced The Weekend Update. Oh, yeah. From 2001. That's a big deal. That's a prestigious position. Yes.
我想大家都知道他在《周六夜现场》起步。他在那里待了六年。在《周六夜现场》期间，他制作了《周末更新》。哦，是的。从2001年开始。这可是个大项目。这是一个很有威望的职位。是的。
He did it from 2001 to 2004. He, of course, was a writer on The Office until 2008. He then went on to co-create Parks and Rec, Brooklyn Nine-Nine, and he created The Good Place and Rutherford Falls with our very own Ed Helms. Wow. Yeah. His resume is full of other shows that he's also produced on and written for. I have to give a shout out to one, Jenna, because I love this show.
他从2001年做到2004年。当然，他在《办公室》担任编剧直到2008年。随后，他联合创作了《公园与游憩》、《神烦警探》，并与我们亲爱的埃德·赫尔姆斯共同创作了《善地》和《默瑟岛》。哇。是的。他的简历上还写满了其他他曾参与制作和编剧的节目。我必须向其中一部致敬，珍娜，因为我太喜欢这个节目了。
Did you know that he co-produced The Comeback with Lisa Kudrow? And he wrote two episodes, and I loved that show. I loved it. I found that out about him in the first season of The Office, and I was like enamored with him. Like to me, that was like superstar status, that he wrote that just amazing satire. It makes me want to go back and rewatch it. I had forgotten that he worked on it.
你知道他和丽莎·库卓共同制作了《喜国》吗？他还写了两集，我太喜欢那个节目了。我太喜欢了。我在《办公室》第一季时发现了这一点，当时我就被他迷住了。对initializeApp我来说，这就像是超级巨星的地位，他写出了如此惊艳的讽刺剧。这让我想回去重新看一遍。我都忘了他也参与过这部剧。
And when I was looking up his credits, I was like, oh, I want to rewatch the comeback. Well, fast fact number three, Mike Schur wrote a book. It's called How to Be Perfect, The Correct Answer to Every Moral Question. Here is how he described it to us in an email. He said, it's a book about how hard it is to be a good person and how we can use ethics and moral philosophy to try not
当我查阅他的履历时，我想，哦，我想重温《喜国》。好吧，快讯第三条，迈克·舒尔写了一本书。书名叫《如何完美：每个道德问题的正确答案》。他在一封邮件中这样向我们描述它：他说，这是一本关于做一个好人有多难的书，以及我们如何利用伦理学和道德哲学来努力避免……
to screw up all the time, but in a funny way, not like in a homework way. The basic idea was to explain all the stuff I learned for the good place without giving everyone a headache. You guys, when we did this interview with Mike, our copies of his book had not arrived yet, but we have them now. And this is a truly special book. I started reading it and I can't stop.
总是搞砸一切，但它是以一种有趣的方式，而不是像做家庭作业那样。基本理念是解释我在《善地》中学到的所有东西，又不会让每个人都头疼。大家，当我们采访迈克时，我们订的书还没寄到，但我们现在已经拿到了。这是一本真正特别的书。我开始读它就停不下来了。
I'm like binging a book. Same. I love it. I couldn't put it down. I was reading it last night. This morning I was like, I want to read more. Like I woke up thinking about it. Do you know what I mean? Yeah. So Mike is such an amazing writer. We already know
我简直是在刷书。我也是。我太喜欢了。我爱不释手。我昨晚还在读。今天早上我就想，我还想读更多。就像我醒来时脑子里还在想它。你知道我的意思吗？是的。所以迈克真的是个不可思议的作家。我们已经知道了……
that, but he takes this conversation of morality and he makes it funny and interesting and relatable. For example, there's a chapter titled, and by the way, all the chapter titles are hilarious, but here's one that cracked me up. There's a chapter titled, Do I have to return my shopping cart to the shopping cart rack thingy? It's all the way over there. Yes. And then basically what he does is he answers that question. And the answer is based on all of these ancient philosophers and, you know, ethics, morality, and moral compass. Yes. So listen, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, you get to listen to Mike Schur. And we get to find out so much about Moe's.
这一点，但他把关于道德的对话变得妙趣横生、引人入胜且贴近生活。例如，有一个章节的标题是，顺便说一句，所有的章节标题都超级搞笑，但有一个把我逗笑了。有一个章节的标题是，我必须把购物车放回购物车推车区吗？它离得那么远呢。是的。基本上他做的是回答了这个问题。而答案是基于所有这些古代哲学家，以及，你知道的，伦理、道德和道德指南针。是的。所以听着，我想我们应该休息一下。当我们回来时，你就可以收听迈克的访谈了。我们将深入了解许多关于莫斯的幕后故事。
It's a treat, we promise. Mike Schur, welcome to be here. I'm a huge fan of you as people, first of all, first and foremost, second of all, you as actors, and then third of all, you as podcasters. This has been such a delight to watch you do this thing to celebrate this show that we all made together. I'm so happy to be here. It's a real honor. Oh, Mike, thank you so much. We love you.
这是一场视听盛宴，我们向你保证。迈克·舒尔，欢迎来到节目。首先，也是最重要的，我是你们所有人的超级粉丝，其次，作为演员的你们，第三，作为播客主持人的你们。看着你们做这个节目来庆祝我们共同创作的作品，真的是一种极大的享受。我很高兴能来到这里。这真的是个莫大的荣幸。哦，迈克，非常感谢你。我们爱死你了。
We're so thrilled to have you here. And I know the fans are going to enjoy just hearing your voice. Jen and I both listened to you quite a bit before this. And we both found you really pleasing to listen to. Really? We like your voice quite a lot. You listened to me in what context? Other podcasts, interviews, podcasts. We do our research here on Office Ladies. Yeah. That's very nice of you to say because I've always found my own voice
我们非常高兴你能来到这里。我知道粉丝们一定会很享受听到你的声音。在这之前，我和珍娜都听过不少你的节目。我们都觉得你的声音听起来非常悦耳。真的吗？我们非常喜欢你的声音。你们是在什么语境下听我的声音？其他播客，采访，播客。我们做过功课的，就在办公室辣妹节目里。是的。你这么说真是太好了，因为我一直觉得自己的声音……
to be slightly annoying, which I think maybe most people do. That you're like it's the phenomenon of hearing your voice played back to you. This is how old we are, is like on an answering machine message or something. You know you'd you'd be like uh is that what I sound like I always feel like I sound a little annoying and nasally but I'm glad to hear you say that. Well I felt that way about myself too and I sort of brushed it off like oh that's just everybody feels that way about their own voice but then we recently re-watched an episode where Michael is trying to get Jim to say something bad about Pam and he gets Jim to admit that Pam's voice is rather shrill sometimes. And I thought, oh, I guess maybe in the writer's room when forced to come up with something annoying about me, we settled on my shrill voice. So thank
稍微有点烦人，我想可能大多数人都是这样。就像当你听到自己的录音回放时的那种现象。这就是我们的年龄体现，就像是在电话答录机留言里什么的。你知道你会想，呃，这就是我的声音吗？我总是觉得自己听起来有点烦人，还有点鼻音，但听到你这么说我很高兴。好吧，我对自己也有这种感觉，我原本把它当成是“哦，大家对自己的声音都有这种感觉”而忽略了，但我们最近重温了一集，迈克试图让吉姆说一些关于帕姆的坏话，他让吉姆承认帕姆的声音有时有点刺耳。我想，哦，也许当年在编剧室里，当被迫想出我身上有什么烦人的地方时，我们最终决定是我的刺耳声音。所以非常……
you so much. Which writer hated your voice? I don't know. Mike, do you know? I'm very, very pleased to say that I think I was gone by the time that was written, so I do not have to answer for that crime. It wasn't you. Well played. It wasn't you.
非常感谢你。哪个编剧讨厌你的声音？我不知道。迈克，你知道吗？我非常非常高兴地宣布，我想在写那一集的时候我已经离开了，所以我不需要为那个罪行负责。不是你。干得漂亮。不是你。
Well, listen, we always like to ask people when they come on the podcast, how did they get their job on The Office? And we know that you did double duty. You were a writer, but then you were also a performer. But let's start with how did you get your job as a writer on the show? So I was writing at Saturday Night Live from 1998 to 2004. My then girlfriend, now wife of 16 years, had moved out to LA and permanently in
好吧，听着，每当有人来上我们的播客时，我们总是喜欢问他们是怎么得到《办公室》的工作的？我们知道你身兼两职。你既是编剧，但同时也是表演者。但让我们先从你是怎么得到该剧编剧工作的开始吧？我在1998年至2004年期间在《周六夜现场》担任编剧。我当时的女友、现在结婚16年的妻子已经搬到了洛杉矶，并且在……
like 2002 and we were dating long distance. And in like 2003, it was like, all right, if this is ever going to really work, either she had to move back to New York or I had to leave and move to LA. And it made more sense for me to move to LA because there are more jobs there. So I gave my like years notice, uh, to Lauren Michaels and said I was leaving at the end of the year and got an agent for the first time in my life because I never needed one and I was like all right I'm moving and the first thing he told me was you know this guy Greg Daniels is adapting the British office for American television and I responded
大约2002年时定居在那儿，我们谈着远距离恋爱。大约在2003年的时候，感觉就是，好吧，如果这段感情真的想要维持下去，要么她得搬回纽约，要么我得离开并搬到洛杉矶。而我搬到洛杉矶更合理，因为那里的工作机会更多。所以我提前一年向洛恩·迈尔斯提出了辞呈，说我将在年底离开，并在我人生中第一次找了经纪人，因为我以前从来不需要经纪人，当时我想，好吧，我要搬家了，他告诉我的第一件事就是，你知道吗，这个叫格雷格·丹尼尔斯的家伙正在把英国版的《办公室》改编成美国电视剧，我的反应是……
what a terrible idea disaster do You shouldn't do this. No one should do this. Because I was a huge fan of the British show. This is such a classic story, right? I was a huge fan of the British show. I thought it was absolutely brilliant. I didn't think there was any way it would ever work in America, but it was like, well, you know,
这真是个糟糕的主意，简直是灾难。你不应该这么做。谁都不应该这么做。因为我是英国原版节目的超级粉丝。这真是一个经典的剧本，对吧？我是英国原版节目的超级粉丝。我认为它绝对是天才之作。我不认为它在美国有任何成功的可能，但感觉就像，好吧，你知道的……
beggars can't be choosers. Like I have to get a job out there. So I came to LA sometime in, I don't even remember like winter, I think like February on an off week at SNL. And I had a bunch of meetings and one of them was with Greg. So most of the meetings I had with producers were pretty standard hour long chats,
人在屋檐下，不得不低头。我得在那里找份工作。所以我大约在……我都记不清了，大概是冬天，像二月份左右，趁着《周六夜现场》的休假周来到了洛杉矶。我开了很多会，其中一个就是和格雷格开会。我和制片人们开的大多数会都挺常规的，就是一个小时左右的聊天……
hey, here's our pilot, watch the pilot and let's talk about the show. And I dutifully tried to, you know, say nice things about whatever they were working on. And then I met with Greg and my meeting with Greg was two hours long, more than two hours long. And it was so different from every other meeting. It was, it was like intense and in depth and fascinating.
嘿，这是我们的试播集，看看试播集然后我们聊聊这个节目。我尽责地试图，你知道的，对他们正在制作的东西说些好话。然后我见到了格雷格，我和格雷格的会议持续了两个小时，超过了两个小时。它与其他所有会议都完全不同。它是如此激烈、深入且迷人。
In the middle of the meeting, he said, I'm very sorry It was like intense and in-depth and fascinating. In the middle of the meeting, he said, I'm very sorry, but my back is acting up. Would you mind if I lied down? And I said, no. And so he lay on the floor on his back in front of me while I sat on his couch. So I think to an outside observer, it would look very much like we were in like Freudian
在会议进行到一半时，他说，非常抱歉……会议既激烈、深入又迷人。在会议进行到一半时，他说，非常抱歉，我的背有点不舒服。你介意我躺一会儿吗？我说，不介意。于是他躺在我的面前，平躺在地板上，而我则坐在他的沙发上。所以我想在旁观者看来，这非常像我们在进行弗洛伊德式的……
analysis where I was his therapist and he was like free associating. I think to an outside observer, it would look very much like we were in Freudian analysis where I was his therapist and he was free associating. But he just asked the most incisive questions, the most penetrating questions about the nature of storytelling and about the British show and why it worked and what he had to do to make it work here. And I left the meeting and I Texted on my like Motorola razor. I texted my agent and I said I
精神分析，我是他的治疗师，而他在自由联想。我想在旁观者看来，这非常像我们在进行弗洛伊德式的精神分析，我是他的治疗师，而他在自由联想。但他只是提出了最敏锐、最透彻的问题，关于讲故事的本质，关于英国原版节目以及为什么它能成功，以及他必须做什么才能让它在这里成功。我离开会议室后，用我的摩托罗拉RAZR手机……给我的经纪人发了一条短信，我说，我……
Don't know if that guy's gonna offer me a job but if he does I'm gonna take it because I think he's gonna teach me how to write and my agent Sends me that text like every four years back to me. He sends it back to me and says like you were right You were right. You're right, so Greg offered me the job and I happily took it and I thought this is obviously not going to work. It's a, it is a, it is a fool's errand to try to adapt this show for an American audience, but he's going to teach me how to write. And that's exactly what happened in that first season.
不知道那家伙会不会给我工作，但如果他给的话，我一定会接受，因为我觉得他会教我怎么写作。我的经纪人每隔四年就会把那条短信发回给我。他把短信发回给我，然后说，你当时是对的。你是对的。你是对的，所以格雷格给了我这份工作，我开心地接受了。当时我想这显然行不通。这是一个，是一个，是一个注定失败的任务，试图为美国观众改编这个节目，但他要教我写作。而这正是在第一季中发生的事情。
You know, the only full-time writers really were me, Mindy and BJ, because Lester Lewis, the late Lester Lewis and Paul E. Racine and Larry Wilmore were consultants. And Mindy and BJ and I had never written anything. We didn't have any idea what we were doing. And Greg basically taught a class. He taught like the true professor he is. He taught a class on how to write and it changed all of our lives forever.
你知道，真正全职的编剧其实只有我、明蒂和BJ，因为已故的莱斯特·刘易斯、保罗·李布斯坦和拉里·威尔莫尔都是顾问。而明蒂、BJ和我以前从来没有写过任何东西。我们根本不知道自己在做什么。格雷格基本上就像在上课。他像一个真正的教授那样授课。他上了一堂关于如何写作的课，这永远改变了我们所有人的生活。
So that's my office origin story. Wow. That is so good. Mike, I remember you guys that first season, there were so few of you and how close you all became because of that. Yeah, it was a tiny little, Greg used to call it a strike force. He was like, this is an elite strike force,
这就是我与《办公室》的渊源。哇。太棒了。迈克，我还记得你们第一季的时候，你们的人数那么少，因为这个，你们所有人都变得非常亲密。是的，那是一个微小的……格雷格以前称之为突击队。他说，这是一支精英突击队。
which I think was just him trying to boost our confidence because we had no idea what we were doing. But it was really, you know, it was a very, very small group of people who were working really, really hard on a very small number of episodes. We only wrote five scripts. Like, you know, we each wrote, we actually wrote,
我想这只是他在试图建立我们的信心，因为我们根本不知道自己在做什么。但真的，你知道的，这是一个非常非常小的群体，他们在一数量非常少的剧集上付出了非常非常多的努力。我们只写了五个剧本。就像，你知道的，我们每个人都写了，实际上我们写了……
we wrote six to make five. I'm not sure if you remember this, but we wrote, or even if you even knew this, Greg, one of the only things that Greg was able to squeeze out of NBC in that first year was he let us write one more script than we would shoot. And so we wrote one extra episode that I think he wrote. And then we just we picked the best five out of the six that we had written and threw the other one away. And I wish I could remember what that other one was. There is a there
我们写了六个来选出五个。我不确定你是否还记得，或者你甚至是否知道这一点，格雷格在第一季能够从NBC那里榨取出来的少数几件东西之一，就是他允许我们比实际拍摄的剧本多写一个。所以我们多写了一集，我想是他写的。然后我们从写好的六个剧本中挑选出最好的五个，把另一个扔掉了。我希望我能记起那另一个是什么。这里有一个……
is a lost. Oh, that'd be a good question for Greg. Yeah, there's a lost season one office episode script out there somewhere that we just never produced. So it was really intense work and it was a combination of story breaking but also just like a master class in how to create television and what makes a good story. There were times when, I've told this story before but there are times when greg was talking. We would be pitching and i had a notebook where i would like just jot down ideas and there would be moments when greg would say. Let's talk about what let's just pause for a second. And talk about like what makes a good story and then he would start kind of like going through the list of things that he felt were crucial
有一个失落的……哦，这对格雷格来说是个好问题。是的，外面某处流传着一集《办公室》第一季的失落剧本，只是我们从未制作它。所以那是非常紧张的工作，它既结合了剧情构思，也堪称关于如何制作电视节目以及是什么造就了一个好故事的大师级课程。有时候，我以前讲过这个故事，但有时候格雷格在说话。我们当时在构思点子，我有一个笔记本，我会把想法随手记下来，有时格雷格会说：我们来谈谈……让我们暂停一秒钟，谈谈是什么造就了一个好故事，然后他会开始罗列那些他认为是至关重要的东西……
to good TV stories. And I would realize like, oh, he's in lecture mode is the way I thought of it was lecture mode, which was a good thing. It sounds like a bad thing, but it was a good thing. And I would turn the page and I would start taking notes like I was in college. And I would just like write down
对好的电视故事至关重要。然后我会意识到，哦，他进入了讲课模式，这是我当时对这种模式的看法，这就是讲课模式，这是一件好事。听起来可能是一件坏事，但其实是一件好事。然后我会翻过一页，开始做笔记，就像我在上大学一样。我会开始写……
as if he were an actual professor and I had a test coming up and I would start just writing down. And I still have those notes and I still go back and look at them every once in a while to like remember, to refresh my memory about what he told us all about storytelling. It was that intense and that sort of foundational and meaningful to all of us. Oh, man. Wow. I do remember those early days about what a small collective we were.
就好像他真的是个教授，而我马上要面临考试一样，我开始奋笔疾书。我至今还留着那些笔记，偶尔还会翻出来看一看，好记起、刷新我对当年他告诉我们关于讲故事的所有事情的记忆。就是那么紧张，那么具有基础性，对我们所有人都意义重大。哦，天哪。哇。我还记得早期的那些日子，我们是一个多么小的集体。
Even our table reads, do you remember? We would just pull up chairs on the stage where we were filming. We would just all grab like a desk chair and sit in a circle and read the script. And I loved that. Mm-hmm. It was really intimate. There were so many cool things about that first season including that the place where we worked was on this weird soundstage in the middle of Culver City or something.
甚至连围读剧本也是，你还记得吗？我们只是把椅子拉到我们拍摄的舞台上。我们所有人随便抓把办公椅围成一个圈，然后开始读剧本。我太喜欢那个了。嗯哼。真的非常亲密。第一季有那么多酷炫的事情，包括我们工作的地方在卡尔弗城中央或者某个地方的一个奇怪的录音棚里。
And so Hollywood soundstages are often, you know, these big gigantic empty rooms where you put sets and then attached to them usually or above them are a suite of offices where the writers and the production staff works. But that suite of offices became the actual set. Like the set that we built was modeled on the crappy offices where the writers were working. And right down to the layout, like Greg was in what would be Michael's office and there was like a reception desk right outside it that became Pam's reception desk. So we would do these drills, Greg would have us do these drills where he would go like,
好莱坞的录音棚通常是那种巨大无比的空房间，你把布景放在里面，通常与它们相连的或者在它们上方的是一组办公室，编剧和制作人员在那里工作。但那组办公室后来成了真正的布景。就像我们搭建的布景是以编剧们工作的破烂办公室为原型建造的。甚至连布局都一样，比如格雷格的办公室就是迈克尔的办公室，外面紧挨着有一个前台，后来成了帕姆的前台。所以我们会进行这些训练，格雷格让我们进行这样的训练，他会说：
okay, take a half an hour and go sit at Pam's desk or go sit in Michael's office, or what will be Michael's office, or go sit where Jim sits and just get a sense of what is your eye line to Pam. He would put Mindy at Pam's reception desk and he would put BJ at Jim's desk. And he would say like, just sit there and like absorb the vibe of like, imagine that you're in love with that person
好吧，花半个小时去帕姆的桌子旁坐坐，或者去迈克尔的办公室坐坐，或者将来会成为迈克尔办公室的地方坐坐，或者去吉姆坐的地方坐坐，感受一下你看帕姆的视线。他让明蒂坐在帕姆的前台，让BJ坐在吉姆的桌子旁。然后他说：就在那里坐着，去吸收那种氛围，想象你爱上了那个人……
and that you have to like angle your chair in such a way so that you can catch a glimpse of her out of the corner of your eye or whatever. And it was fascinating, it was really interesting. And I remember at one point he had me go into work in Michael's office or what the office that would be the model for Michael's office. And I remember hating it.
并且你必须以某种方式调整椅子的角度，这样你才能从眼角余光瞥见她，诸如此类。这太迷人了，真的很有趣。我记得有一次他让我去迈克尔的办公室工作，或者说那个将成为迈克尔办公室原型的办公室。我记得我讨厌那样。
Cause it was like, I was in this, I was far away from everything and all this. And I would see people talking through the windows and I'd be like, what are they talking about? And I had the urge to like go out and like do what Michael did all the time, which was like, hey, what's going on? And he knew so much about what he wanted out of the show,
因为感觉就像，我在这个地方，我离所有东西都很远，诸如此类。我看到人们透过窗户聊天，我会想：他们在聊什么呢？我有一种冲动想走出去，做迈克尔经常做的事，那就是：嘿，怎么啦？他对这部剧的诉求了如指掌……
that he would practice not just the skill of writing the characters, but the skill of embodying them or emotionally connecting to them. And that's what I mean when I say it was professorial. It wasn't just like, all right, what's episode two? What's the act break? What's the first act break for the season finale? It was really like, we had to embody the characters and understand them emotionally and socially
以至于他不仅练习编写角色的技巧，还练习体现角色的技巧或与他们建立情感联系。这就是我所说的教授级别的意思。这不仅仅是：好吧，第二集是什么？幕间休息是什么？季终集的第一个幕间休息是什么？真的就像，我们必须体现角色并在情感和社交上理解他们……
in a way that I think led to great episodes, you know? Well, it's so interesting because when all the actors got there, then they did that to us too. They made us sit at our desks and just sit there and feel it. We've talked about that before. And so I love that that started all the way back with you guys writing the episodes. Yeah, June of 2004, like right from the jump,
以一种我认为能带来精彩剧集的方式，你知道吗？嗯，这太有趣了，因为当所有演员到齐后，他们也对我们做了同样的事。他们让我们坐在办公桌前，就那样坐着去感受它。我们以前讨论过这个。所以我很喜欢这种做法从你们创作剧本的时候就开始了。是的，2004年6月，从一开始……
there were things like that that we did that weren't the typical things that you would do with a writing staff. Another thing he did all the time, which I thought was so smart, which I still do on shows that I work on now, is we would come into work one day and he would put all the characters names on a board and he would pick two of them at random.
我们做过诸如此类的事情，这些都不是你通常会和编剧团队一起做的事。他经常做的另一件事，我认为非常聪明，我到现在在我现在工作的节目中也还在用，就是我们有一天来上班，他会把所有角色的名字写在黑板上，然后随机挑选两个。
He would give them to, he would say, me and Larry Wilmore like go come up with five story ideas for Oscar and Kelly and then and then you Mindy and Paul like go come up with five story ideas for you know Jim and Stanley and it for an hour we would just pitch okay okay, well what the hell could a story be with Oscar and Kelly? But it led to some really cool stuff and like some of those, some of the little B stories and the C stories of, that came, that were in the first couple of seasons were just brainstorming like random pairings of people. He understood fundamentally
他会把名字交给……他会说：我和拉里·威尔莫尔，去为奥斯卡和凯利想五个故事创意，然后你们明蒂和保罗去为奥斯卡和凯利想五个故事创意，然后你们明蒂和保罗，去为……你知道的，吉姆和斯丹利想五个故事创意。然后持续一个小时，我们就只是推销点子，好吧，好吧，奥斯卡和凯利能有什么故事啊？但它确实带来了一些非常酷的东西，比如前几季中出现的一些B线剧情和C线剧情，都只是通过头脑风暴随机搭配人物产生的。他从根本上理解……
that one of the great advantages that the show had over other shows is that we had twenty people we had like most shows have whatever. Six main characters or something and so pretty quickly you get tired of a story with involving these two people there these three people. involving these two people or these three people. And he was like, that's not what this is gonna be. This is gonna be a, the whole point of the show is to observe like an anthropologist, observe the comings and goings of a large number of people in the same office environment. So like go work on random pairings
该剧相比其他剧集的一大巨大优势在于，我们有二十个人。大多数剧集都有什么呢？六个主要角色左右，所以很快你就会厌倦涉及这两个人或三个人的故事。涉及这两个人或三个人的故事。他说，这不是我们要做的。重点是，整部剧的意义在于像人类学家一样去观察，观察同一个办公环境中大量人群的进进出出。所以，去研究随机组合……
and like sometimes really fun stuff would come out of it. You know, like he just so thoroughly understood what made the show special and what the potential was for how good it could be, that he had all of these machinations and he was always moving pieces around the chessboard with the writers in those early days, you know? Yeah, I remember telling my dad,
有时候真的会有非常有趣的东西产生。你知道的，就像他非常彻底地理解是什么让这部剧变得特别，以及它能变得多优秀的潜力，所以他有所有这些筹码，在早期那些日子里，他总是和编剧们在棋盘上移动棋子，你知道吗？是的，我记得我告诉我爸爸……
I was trying to describe this group of people and the show to my dad, who was not at all in entertainment, you know, he was a drilling engineer, but sometimes we could talk sports. And I said, dad, here's the deal. We have a deep bench, dad. And it was like a basketball term, like our team is so good.
我当时试图向我爸爸描述这群人和这部剧，他完全不属于娱乐界，你知道的，他是一名钻井工程师，但有时我们可以聊聊体育。我对他说：爸爸，情况是这样的。我们板凳深度很厚，爸爸。这就像一个篮球术语，就像我们的团队太棒了。
There's so many layers to this team. And then when he came and, you know, Greg invited them to sit at a table read at lunch, my dad was like, I get it, I get it. I get it now, yeah. I get it, like, because there were laughs, I think, coming from him and all these places, you know? Yeah.
这个团队有很多层次。然后当他来的时候，你知道的，格雷格邀请他们坐在桌边午餐围读剧本时，我爸爸说：我懂了，我懂了。我现在懂了，是的。我懂了，因为有笑声，我想，从他身上和所有这些地方传来，你知道吗？是的。
Well, I was gonna say that in season nine, John and I were invited to be producers on the show to kind of help carve out Jim and Pam's final season. And we got to come into their writers room mostly as observers. And Greg was running the show that season and he was still doing those exercises. And it was fascinating. Except in this case, it was more like homework. I remember the day started and Greg said, okay, get out your homework.
嗯，我要说的是，在第九季中，约翰和我被邀请成为该剧的制片人，来帮助打造吉姆和帕姆的最后一季。我们大部分时间作为观察员进入了他们的编剧室。格雷格那一季负责运作节目，他依然在做那些练习。这太迷人了。除了这次，它更像是家庭作业。我记得那天开始时，格雷格说：好了，拿出你们的家庭作业。
What? And the homework had been that everyone had to come up with five ideas for, I can't remember what it was, but it was like for a Dwight and Stanley cold open. Go. And then you would just sit and listen. And then when there was an idea that piqued his interest, he would say, oh, oh, okay, you two go off, flesh that out. And then two people would leave the room and then we would keep listening to the homework.
什么？家庭作业是每个人都必须为……我不记得具体是什么了，但就像是德怀特和斯丹利的开场冷戏想出五个点子。开始。然后你就坐在那里听。当有一个点子激起他的兴趣时，他会说：哦，哦，好吧，你们两个去吧，把那个丰满起来。然后两个人离开房间，我们继续听家庭作业。
And I remember thinking, oh my gosh, I would be so terrified to present my five ideas because sometimes it was just crickets. Like you could just hear the ideas just die in the room. I mean, what an intense and vulnerable thing to pitch your creative ideas in front of like a room of people who are all judging whether or not you should follow that thread.
我记得当时想，哦天哪，要是在一屋子都在评判你是否应该顺着那个思路往下走的人面前展示我的五个点子，我会吓坏的，因为有时候现场一片沉寂。就像你能听到那些点子直接在房间里夭折一样。我的意思是，在满满一屋子人面前抛出你的创意点子，是一件多么紧张且脆弱的事情啊。
Yes, one of his greatest strengths is that he is unafraid, I would say, of failure. And I think, I believe that that comes, I'm guessing that that comes partially from working at Saturday Night Live because what you just described of like pitching ideas and having them bomb, right? That is the essence of working at SNL. Except your failures at SNL are public. Like you write sketches and there's a read through with the entire cast of the show and Lauren and all the producers around a giant table and the audience is 150 people who work on the show.
是的，他最大的优点之一是，我可以说，他不害怕失败。而且我认为，我相信这部分来自于在《周六夜现场》工作的经历，因为你刚才描述的那些抛出点子却遭遇滑铁卢的经历，对吧？那正是《周六夜现场》工作的精髓所在。只不过你在《周六夜现场》的失败是公开的。就像你写了短剧，然后和节目的整个演员阵容、洛恩以及所有制片人围着一张巨型桌子进行围读，而台下坐着150个在该节目工作的人。
And by the way, a very famous person who's hosting the show, like, you know, Drake is reading your sketch or whatever. Oh my God. And there are moments at SNL where, you know, your sketches are 12 pages long or whatever, and your sketch starts and you get to page two and like the joke of the sketch is sprung and no one laughs. And in your head, you're like, there's 10 more pages.
而且顺便说一句，像德 Drake 这样主持节目的非常有名的人，在读你的小品或者别的什么。哦，天哪。在周六夜现场，有时候你的小品有12页长，然后你的小品开始了，当你读到第二页时，小品里的笑话却抖出来了，结果没人笑。在你的脑海里，你会想，还有10页呢。
Like we have to sit here for 10 more pages as no one finds my premise funny. And so for the first, I don't know what Greg's experience was, I've never really talked to him about his time there, but for the first like six months, you fall into a deep depression. Like it's just like,
就像我们必须在这里再坐10页的时间，而没有人觉得我的设定好笑。所以对于前六个月，我不知道格雷格的经历是什么，我从来没跟他聊过他在那里的时光，但对于前六个月左右，你会陷入深深的抑郁中。就像是，
it's so embarrassing to fail that way publicly. And then the week goes by and the show happens. And then it's like, all right, it's Monday again, do it again. And you like do it again, and you fail again, and you fail and you fail and you fail. And eventually, at some point, hopefully, you kind of figure it out. And you write a sketch and it gets some laughs. And you're like, okay, it's not the end of the world. Like, I'm still here.
以那种公开的方式失败是如此尴尬。然后一周过去了，节目播出了。接着就像是，好吧，又是星期一，再来一次。然后你再来一次，又失败了，你不断地失败、失败、失败。最终，在某个时刻，希望你能摸索出门道。你写了一个小品，赢得了一些笑声。你会想，好吧，这不是世界末日。至少，我还在这里。
And then you get a little better and a little better. And that, like that theory is, it's pretty brutal on your ego, but when you've already had it driven out of your ego from working at SNL, like five Stanley cold opens, I can, oh, who cares? No problem. Yeah, exactly. So I, that, and his theory is really like,
然后你变得稍微好一点，再好一点。这种理论对你的自尊心来说相当残酷，但当你的自尊心已经在周六夜现场经受过摧残之后——比如经历了五个斯坦利式的开场白——我就会想，哦，谁在乎呢？没问题。是的，完全是这样。所以我觉得，他的理论其实是，
this is a numbers game. Like the way to get to the best ideas is you have to create a thousand ideas in order to find the two that are good. And he took that approach with everything. He took that approach when he was hiring writers. He took that approach when he was casting people. I mean, how long did the casting process go on
这是一场概率游戏。通往最佳创意的途径是，你必须创造一千个创意，才能从中找到两个好的创意。他在所有事情上都采取这种方法。他在雇佣编剧时采取这种方法。他在选角时也采取这种方法。我的意思是，选角过程持续了多久？
for the show? Endlessly long, endlessly, endlessly long. And that's just his, he's just the most thorough person when it comes to that. He doesn't settle for anything. He demands that you walk down. I mean, when we were breaking stories, like we would get five sixth of the way down the line
为了这个节目？没完没了，没完没了，没完没了。这就是他的风格，说到做事，他是最一丝不苟的人。他绝不妥协。他要求你深入推进。我的意思是，当我们构思故事时，我们会在接近完成
toward breaking a story and we'd get to a point where he would realize it didn't work and he even go like, man, this doesn't work, throw it away, start over. And it's really exhausting but also the show lasted for 10 years and it was really good. And here we are still talking about it. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, 17 years later. Wow. Well, now I think we have to ask you, Mike. Yeah, we do. How did you come to play Moe's? Yeah.
五分之六进度的时候构思好一个故事，然后我们会发现它行不通，他甚至会说，天哪，这行不通，扔掉它，重新开始。这真的很累人，但这个节目也持续了10年，而且真的很棒。现在我们还在讨论它。是的，完全正确。是的，17年之后。哇。好吧，现在我觉得我们得问问你，迈克。是的，我们必须问。你是怎么开始扮演摩斯的？是的。
Something we understand you hated. You hated being Moe's, but we love Moe's. Let me just delineate here importantly. I love the fact that I played Moe's. I hated actually doing it because for two reasons. So here's the story. The story was in the... Greg always had it as part of Dwight Schrute's backstory
据我们所知，你很讨厌这个角色。你讨厌当摩斯，但我们很喜欢摩斯。让我在这里明确一点。我很喜欢我扮演过摩斯这件事。我只是讨厌实际去演，原因有二。所以故事是这样的。故事是这样的……格雷格一直把这个作为德怀特·舒鲁特背景故事的一部分，
that he himself was not Amish or Mennonite or anything like that, but he was sort of Amish adjacent, that he had relatives. He was of Germanic descent living in Pennsylvania. That alone is sort of Amish adjacent. So Greg always had it in the back of his head that there was a sort of cousin, a shrewd cousin farming community
他本人不是阿米什人、门诺派教徒或类似的人，但他算是有阿米什背景的人，他有一些亲戚。他是具有日耳曼血统并住在宾夕法尼亚州的人。光是这一点就有点接近阿米什人了。所以格雷格的脑海里一直觉得，可能有一个表亲，一个舒鲁特表亲的农场社区，
that was either Amish or something in the Amish family. So in 2004, there was a reality show called Amish in the City. Yes, yes, I saw that. Yes, it was a terrible, terrible program. It was so hard to watch. It was so awful and my wife and I watched it and I was sort of trying to express how cringy it was
要么是阿米什人，要么与阿米什家族有关。所以在2004年，有一个真人秀节目叫做《城里的阿米什人》。是的，是的，我看过。是的，那是一个非常非常糟糕的节目。看它太痛苦了。太糟糕了，我和我妻子一起看了它，我当时试图向编剧室表达这个节目有多么令人尴尬，
to the writers room one day. The premise of the show was they took a bunch of idiot club kids from l.a. Who are on spring break and they were like you guys are gonna come stay in this awesome house in the hollywood hills and they were psyched and they were like we're gonna get so drunk and party and whatever what they didn't know that also invited to stay in the house. Where a bunch of young amish folks on Rumspringa who had been released for their year of exploration and they were going to live together and then you know... Hot mess ensues. Hot mess ensues, right. So one of the characters on the show who was Amish was named Moe's. And Moe's was this delightful, kindhearted, fragile egg who tried his best to become friends
有一天。这个节目的设定是，他们从洛杉矶找了一群愚蠢的夜店年轻人，他们正值春假，节目组对他们说，你们要来好莱坞山这个棒极了的房子里住，他们兴奋极了，心想我们要喝得酩酊大醉，狂欢一番之类的。他们不知道的是，同样被邀请住进这个房子的，
with the idiot club kids from LA. And among other ways that he tried this where he fashioned his own wooden toys, like a little wooden airplane or a little wooden car. He made them himself. He made them himself. He made them himself and he presented them to his new friends and they were just like, what the hell is this?
还有一群正在经历“青春期自由探索期”（Rumspringa）的年轻阿米什人，他们被允许出来体验外面的世界一年。他们将住在一起，然后你知道的……一团糟接踵而至。一团糟接踵而至，对吧。所以节目中其中一个阿米什人名叫摩斯。摩斯是个可爱、心地善良、像鸡蛋一样脆弱的人，他竭尽全力想和洛杉矶那些愚蠢的夜店年轻人交朋友，
Right? And so I was like relating this story to the room about how like awful this show was. And Greg pointed at me with his giant finger. I remember it so clearly and said, you're gonna play Moe's, you're Dwight's cousin, you're Moe's. And I was like, ha ha ha. And he was like, no, I'm serious, that we're gonna do this, you're gonna play Moe's.
他尝试这样做的方式之一就是自己制作木制玩具，比如一个小木飞机或一个小木车。他自己做的。他自己做的。他自己制作并把它们送给新朋友，而他们的反应却是，这到底是什么鬼？
And I thought it was a joke for a couple reasons. First, because I thought it was a joke. Second, because all of the other writers, as you may know, got to play essentially like versions of themselves or significant characters in the show. Like Mindy was in the show all the time and Paul was in the show all the time and BJ was in the show all the time. And Greg was essentially saying, you are a joke
对吧？所以我把这个故事讲给编剧室听，讲这个节目有多么糟糕。格雷格用他巨大的手指指着我。我记得太清楚了，他说，你要演摩斯，你是德怀特的表亲，你就是摩斯。我当时想，哈哈哈。而他说，不，我是认真的，我们要这么做，你要演摩斯。
and I'm gonna turn you into a joke. And then, so the first time that we did it, it was in a photo. It was when, when Rain just says, I have a cousin, I in a photo. It was when, Yes. when Rain just says, I have a cousin, I run a beet farm with my cousin, Moses. It was in an episode I wrote. It was the one where Michael buys a condo.
我以为这是一个玩笑，原因有二。首先，我以为这只是个玩笑。其次，正如你所知，其他所有的编剧基本上都扮演了他们自己的一些版本，或者是剧中的重要角色。比如敏迪一直在剧里，保罗一直在剧里，B.J.一直在剧里。而格雷格的意思是，你就是一个笑话，
Yes. And it was just a photo. And I was like, great. I'll put on a fake beard and, actually, I don't even think I had the beard for the photo, but I'll dress up in these wool clothes and we'll take a photo and that'll be the end of it. But then the writers, my so-called friends,
我要把你变成一个笑话。然后，我们第一次拍这个角色的时候，是在一张照片里。那是当雷恩说，我有一个表亲，我在一张照片里。那是当，是的。当雷恩说，我有一个表亲，我和我的表亲摩西一起经营一个甜菜农场。那是在我写的一集里。也就是迈克尔买公寓的那一集。
got very excited about me playing Moe's and started writing me into episodes all the time. And it was the episode BJ wrote, the initiation where Dwight was trying to initiate Ryan into some kind of salesman fraternity by bringing him to his farm. And they wrote Mo's into the show. And so Greg insisted for this episode that I have a real beard.
是的。那只是一张照片。我想，太好了。我会戴上假胡子，其实，我觉得拍那张照片时我甚至没有胡子，但我会穿上这些羊毛衣服，拍张照片，这就结束了。但后来编剧们，也就是我所谓的“朋友”们，
He didn't believe that a fake beard, according to him, would look real. And I was like, listen, I don't grow facial hair very easily. It's gonna take me a long time. He's like, well, you better get started. It was basically just hazing. That's all it was.
对让我扮演摩斯感到非常兴奋，并开始不断把我写进剧集里。那是B.J.写的一集，也就是入会仪式那一集，德怀特试图通过带瑞恩去他的农场，让瑞恩加入某种推销员兄弟会。他们把摩斯写进了剧里。所以格雷格坚持要求这一集我必须留真的胡子。
So I grew a real beard for months and months and months. And in that time, this show was nominated for an Emmy. And Greg and I and some of the other producers went around and had a bunch of like fancy Hollywood events that we went to and in every one of those photos I have the disgusting wiry mose beard. And then, so that episode was supposed to be
他不相信假胡子在他看来会显得逼真。我说，听着，我的面部毛发生长得不是很快。这需要很长时间。他说，好吧，你最好现在就开始。这基本上就是一种恶整。这就是全部内容。
the first one we shot in season three, but then there was a, I can't remember why, there was some kind of production issue or script issue or something, and it got delayed like two or three more months. So that I had to keep, and I realized like, I remember like this sweating panic of like, I was counting down the days until I could shave.
所以我留了几个月的真胡子。在那期间，这部剧获得了艾美奖提名。格雷格和我还有其他一些制片人四处奔走，参加了许多花哨的好莱坞活动，在每一张照片里，我都留着那个恶心的、硬邦邦的摩斯胡子。然后，那一集本来应该
And I was like, oh no, now I can't shave now and then grow the beard back in time. So I had to keep it like another three months. And then by the time we finally shot it, it was like mid September in deep in the valley on that Disney Ranch Valley location where we shot Reign's Dwight's Farm. It was the day we shot that first episode,
是我们第三季拍摄的第一集，但后来，我不记得为什么了，出了一些制作问题、剧本问题还是别的什么，推迟了大约两三个月。所以我不得不继续保持这个状态，我记得那种焦虑得冒汗的感觉，我在倒计时等待我可以刮胡子的日子。
the high that day was 105. And I was wearing long johns and wool pants and a wool shirt and suspenders and these old work boots that were incredibly uncomfortable. And I had to run around and pretend to wrestle Ryan. And like, I was just like, I was like a ghost. Like I was just like running through, I was like a horror movie ghost
我想，哦不，现在我不能刮胡子，然后又不能及时把胡子重新留起来。所以我不得不又留了三个月。等我们终于开拍的时候，已经是9月中旬了，在迪士尼牧场的山谷深处，我们在那里拍摄了雷恩扮演的德怀特农场。我们拍第一集的那天，
running through the background of scenes. It took an entire day. I had to get up at 4.30 in the morning to get to Disney Ranch by 5.30. And I was like, well, at least I'll never have to do that again. And then the writers, my so-called friends, wrote me into like a hundred more episodes. So I'm very honored and happy to have played a small, silly role in the history of the show on screen, but the actual act of doing it was always 105. They always, I was always shirtless on a seesaw
那天的最高气温是105华氏度。我穿着秋衣、羊毛裤、羊毛衬衫、背带，还有一双极其不舒服的老旧工作靴。我得跑来跑去，假装和瑞恩摔跤。我觉得自己就像个鬼魂。就像在场景的背景中奔跑，我感觉自己像个恐怖电影里的鬼魂，
or running alongside a car like a dog, or in probably the scariest moment of my life, being slapped like being punched in the face essentially by Angela Kinsey. I know. That was one of the most terrifying moments of my life. Do you remember that when we had to do that? Yes, I was gonna talk to you about it
在背景里跑来跑去。花了一整天时间。我不得不早上4点半起床，以便在5点半赶到迪士尼牧场。我想，好吧，至少我再也不用经历这个了。然后那些编剧，我所谓的“朋友”们，又把我写进了另外上百集里。所以，能在这个剧的历史上扮演一个微小而滑稽的荧幕角色，我感到非常荣幸和高兴，但实际去演的过程总是伴随着105度的高温。他们总是让我穿着背心在一个跷跷板上，
because Angela and Mo's had so many actual scenes together and a lot of them are in the deleted scenes. I'm watching the DVDs. Some made it in, but a few really cracked me up. But I have to talk to you about that one. First I want to say there was a deleted scene in The Surplus where I'm at Shroop Farms with Andy. We're wedding planning.
或者像狗一样跟在一辆车旁奔跑，或者在我生命中最吓人的时刻之一，基本上是被安吉拉·金斯利像扇耳光一样打在脸上。我知道。那是我一生中最可怕的时刻之一。你还记得我们不得不拍那一幕的时候吗？是的，我正想跟你聊聊这个，
Dwight is our wedding planner. We're trying to discuss a butter sculpture and Andy's signing all these papers and you're coming in the kitchen and I hiss at you. Like a cat. And then you run away and we kept breaking at this because it was so absurd. So there's that moment. Like what is Angela and Mo's? What is their relationship? But then the episode he's talking about, I want to, cause I wrote it. It's the finale. It's the series finale.
德怀特是我们的婚礼策划师。我们当时在讨论一个黄油雕塑，安迪在签一堆文件，然后你走进厨房，我对你发出嘶嘶声。就像猫一样。然后你跑开鸟，我们当时一直笑场，因为太荒谬了。所以就有这么个瞬间。安吉拉和莫兹是什么关系？他们的关系是什么？但接下来他说的这集，我想谈谈，因为是我写的。那是最后一集。是剧集的最终集。
No, that's when you kidnapped me. Oh, right, right, right. Okay, the episode was free family portrait and Angela is chasing who she thinks is Dwight in Dwight's car, but it's Mo's dressed as Dwight because she wants to find out if Dwight's found out about her baby, right? Right, right.
不，那是你绑架我的时候。哦，对，对，对，对了。好吧，那一集是“免费全家福”，安吉拉开着车在追她以为是德怀特的人，但其实是打扮成德怀特样子的莫兹，因为她想知道德怀特是不是知道了她孩子的事，对吧？对，对。
And one of the things I remember, which is crazy in hindsight, Mike, is that you and I did our own stunt driving where we had to screech into a cul-de-sac and pull side by side, like really fast, turn on a dime, and then I fly out of the car because they didn't want to waste any time, lose all that footage, and I run up,
我记得的一件事，现在回想起来觉得太疯狂了，迈克，就是你和我亲自上阵做特技开车，我们得尖叫着冲进一个 cul-de-sac（尽头路），然后并排停下，速度超级快，急转弯，然后我从车里飞出去，因为他们不想浪费任何时间，失去所有这些镜头，我跑过去，
and I swing open the door, and it's Moe's and not Dwight, and you won't tell me where Dwight is, and they wanted me to slap the shit out of you. Right. So what happened was, we were like, okay, you and I just were like, so let's just walk through how this happens, and you were kind of like, okay, so I'll come over here, and then I'll get out here, and you'll stand against the car, and then I'll were like, so let's just like walk through how this happens. And you were kind of like, okay, so I'll come over here
然后我猛地拉开车门，里面是莫兹而不是德怀特，而且你不肯告诉我德怀特在哪里，他们想让我狠狠地扇你一巴掌。对。所以当时的情况是，我们当时想，好吧，你和我就像是，那我们先走一遍这个过程是怎么发生的，然后你差不多就是，好吧，那我会过来，然后我从这里下车，你靠在车上，然后我就会——我们就好像是，那我们就走一遍这个过程是怎么发生的。然后你差不多就是，好吧，那我会过来
and then I'll get out here and you'll stand against the car and then I'll slap you. And you like just sort of moved your hand in the motion of what it would be. You did a fakey and I was like, okay, yeah, this seems okay. So we do the first take, we screech up, we do a good job of doing our own stunts by the way.
然后我从这里下车，你靠在车上，然后我扇你一巴掌。然后你就只是用手做了一下那个动作。你做了一个假动作，然后我就想，好吧，好吧，这看起来没问题。所以我们拍了第一个镜头，我们尖叫着停下，顺便说一句，我们自己做特技做得挺好的。
You and me. You pull me out, you're like, where's Dwight, where's Dwight? I'm like, I don't know, or something. And then you slapped me, but you slapped me for real. You hit me so hard, I spun around like a top and like hit the roof of the car and was like, my ears were ringing. And I remember like, I was like, oh, I can't hear what she's saying to me because my ears are ringing so loudly. Oh my God Mike I'm so sorry you know Matt Sohn told me he was like Angela you're gonna have to really hit him because we're pretty wide it'll be you won't be able to do the fakie.
你和我。你把我拉出来，你说，德怀特在哪，德怀特在哪？我说，我不知道，或者类似的话。然后你扇了我，但你是来真的。你打我打得太狠了，我像陀螺一样转了一圈，还撞到了车顶，当时我的耳朵一直在嗡嗡作响。我记得当时我就想，哦，我听不清她对我说什么了，因为我的耳朵嗡嗡得太厉害了。哦天哪，迈克，我真的很抱歉，你知道马特·索恩跟我说，他当时说，安吉拉，你得真的打他，因为我们拍得很广，你没法用假动作。
Yes and and I and I I also remember this is not your fault none of this is your fault. I feel so bad I felt so bad. No because and I because I remember saying no really hit me because I'm six feet tall you are not six feet tall. I am so bad. I felt so bad. No, because I remember saying, no, really hit me, because I'm six feet tall, you are not six feet tall. I am five one. Right? And I was like, no, I hate it when there's like a fake slap on TV. I'm sure this will be fine. Just really hit me, it'll be fine.
是的，而且——而且我也记得——这不是你的错，这都不是你的错。我觉得太糟糕了，我当时觉得太糟糕了。不，因为——而且因为我记得我说过，不，真的打我，因为我身高六英尺，你可没有六英尺高。我太糟糕了。我当时觉得太糟糕了。不，因为我记得我说过，不，真的打我，因为我身高六英尺，你可没有六英尺高。我身高只有五尺一寸。对吧？然后我就想，不，我讨厌电视里那种假打。我相信这会没事的。就真的打我吧，没事的。
I remember telling you that. Oh boy. Like just really hit me, it'll be fine, it'll be fine. I had no idea that you were a mixed martial arts professional. And you hit me so hard I really like lost my, I did not know where I was. I didn't know what was happening. My eyes went blank and my hearing dropped out and I had no idea what was happening. It was wonderful. I'm so, it, and that's the take they used, thankfully. Because afterwards, also, I remember
我记得我跟你说过这个。天哪。就像真的打我一样，没事的，没事的。我根本不知道你是个综合格斗职业选手。你打我打得太狠了，我真的有点……我不知道自己在哪里了。我不知道发生了什么。我的眼前往空洞，听力也下降了，我完全不知道发生了什么。太棒了。我太——而且那是他们最终采用的镜头，谢天谢地。因为事后，我也记得
afterwards you were like, oh my God, I'm so sorry. And I was like, no, no, no, I just didn't understand how strong you were. Oh my gosh, muggers beware. Okay, Angela, Kinsey. I do remember, I felt so bad. And I remember saying, I was trying to like think, why, why, why was that so hard? Maybe it was the momentum, because I'm running. I was was trying to
事后你说，天哪，我太抱歉了。然后我说，不，不，不，我只是不明白你力气这么大。哦天哪，暴徒们小心了。好吧，安吉拉·金西。我确实记得，我当时觉得太糟糕了。我记得我说过，我当时一直在想，为什么，为什么，为什么那一巴掌那么重？也许是因为动量，因为我在奔跑。我当时在想
think about, I don't know where the ninja came from, Mike. I think that slapping is just a more shocking thing than you. I've never been slapped in my life, I'm proud to say. And so I think I just greatly underestimated the force of the blow that was about to hit my face. But this is all part of this larger conversation of why it wasn't fun to play Moe's. It's because not only was it always a sight gag, but also sometimes the writers would write actual lines for me and then in the edit it would always be like,
思考，我不知道这个忍者是从哪里来的，迈克。我觉得扇耳光只是一件比你想象中更让人震惊的事。我很自豪地说，我这辈子从来没挨过耳光。所以我觉得我大大低估了即将击中我脸庞的那一巴掌的力度。但这其实是关于“为什么扮演莫兹并不好玩”这一更广泛讨论的一部分。不仅因为这总是一个视觉笑话，还因为有时编剧会为我写真正的台词，然后在剪辑时总是变成：
yeah, it's funnier if we don't hear from Moe's, right? So they would cut all the lines. And then it was like, what is the most humiliating way that we can use him? then it was like, what is the most humiliating way that we can use him? And it was like being slapped, like in an outhouse with his pants around his ankles while the door is slamming closed. Like it was just, it was Greg's and the writer's way
是的，如果我们不让莫兹发声，会更好笑，对吧？所以他们会剪掉所有的台词。然后就变成了，我们能用他的最羞辱人的方式是什么？然后就变成了，我们能用他的最羞辱人的方式是什么？就像挨耳光一样，像是在旱厕里裤子褪到脚踝，同时门砰的一声关上。这只是格雷格和编剧们的一种方式
of just like enjoying tormenting me. So now when I look back, I'm so happy that I did it. But every time I had to like leave the writer's room, a place where I knew what I was doing, and go be a performer where I did not know what I was doing, I was always a little bit like, this is torture. I always felt like it was a little bit of torture. mows very often? There are certainly times when I'm recognized for that yes. I mean I'm older I'm 17 years older and my hair is a lot grayer and so people don't don't recognize me as often as you would think they would given how popular the show still is. I will say that like my son went to a basketball camp a couple summers ago and I went to pick him up from the camp. And my son had just watched the show,
就像是喜欢折磨我一样。所以现在回想起来，我很高兴我做了这件事。但每次我不得不离开编剧室——那个我知道自己在做什么的地方——去当一个我不知道自己在做什么的表演者时，我总是有点觉得，这简直是折磨。我总是觉得这有点像折磨。经常扮演莫兹吗？当然有时候我会被认出来，是的。我是说我老了，我老了17岁，头发灰白了很多5，所以人们不像你想象的那样经常认出我来，考虑到这部剧现在依然这么受欢迎。我要说的是，几年前我儿子去参加一个篮球夏令营，我去夏令营接他。我儿子刚刚看过这部剧，
I think he was 10 or 11, and he had just watched the whole show. And he was very excited to tell people that I wrote for it and that I played Moe's. And so I went to pick him up from the camp, and one of his counselors, I walked over to where the kids were, and one of his counselors saw me coming,
我想他当时10岁或11岁，他刚刚看完整部剧。他非常兴奋地告诉别人我为这部剧写过剧本，而且我还演了莫兹。所以我去夏令营接他，他的一个辅导员——我走到孩子们待的地方，他的一个辅导员看到我走过来，
and he just broke into this huge smile and was like, hey! And I was like, all right, this guy knows what I was most. And like, you know, he's gonna tell when people recognize me. I did also, when the pandemic first hit, I did a fundraiser for LA Regional Food Bank, which is a charity I really like. The LA Regional Food Bank gives out food to a lot of people in LA County. And I said, like, all right, I'm gonna try to raise money for LA Regional Food Bank. And I'll match donations up to, I can't remember what it was, some $25,000 or something.
然后他脸上露出了灿烂的笑容，说，嘿！然后我就想，好吧，这家伙知道我演过莫兹。而且你知道的，当人们认出我时他会说出来。我还记得，在疫情刚爆发时，我为洛杉矶地区食物银行做了一场募捐活动，这是一个我非常喜欢的慈善机构。洛杉矶地区食物银行向洛杉矶郡的许多人分发食物。我说，好吧，我要试着为洛杉矶地区食物银行筹集资金。我会匹配捐款，最高可达——我不记得是多少了，大概2.5万美元左右。
And like very quickly, donations started pouring in. And then like a true moron, I said, if we raise $50,000 by the end of the day, I will shave my head. And that, and it was a joke, but like that caused donations to really pour in. And to the point where like it was like within an hour, we were at like $50,000.
就像非常快地，捐款开始如潮水般涌来。然后就像一个真正的智障一样，我说，如果我们能在今天结束前筹集到5万美元，我就把头发剃光。然后，那其实是个玩笑，但那却让捐款真的如潮水般涌来。到了那种地步，就像是在一小时内，我们就达到了5万美元左右。
And so then I was like, oh, I see the game. The game is humiliation, right? Like if I just, if I offer humiliation, like we'll raise more money. So then I put it up as a poll and said, would you rather have me shave my head or grow the Mo's beard? And grow the Mo's beard won in a landslide.
然后我就想，哦，我懂这个游戏了。这个游戏就是羞辱，对吧？如果我只是——如果我主动提供羞辱，我们就能筹集到更多资金。所以我把它发成了一个投票，问大家：你们是愿意让我剃光头，还是愿意让我留莫兹的胡子？结果留莫兹的胡子以压倒性优势获胜。
So I had, so over the, in the early, in like May, June, July of 2020, I spent like, again, like three months growing the beard out and then shaved my mustache. So I just had the beard, neckbeard. And around that time, I got recognized, even with masks, I got recognized like everywhere I went. Like that was a big, that was like a big Mo's moment. Cause it was right when the pandemic hit,
所以我就——在2020年的早期，大约在5月、6月、7月，我花了大概——又是花了三个月的时间把胡子留长，然后把小胡子剃掉了。所以我只有大胡子和脖子上的胡子。大约在那段时间里，我被认出来了，即使戴着口罩，无论走到哪里我也都被认出来了。那真是一个重大时刻，可以说是莫兹的一个高光时刻。因为正值疫情爆发之时，
everybody was streaming the show. Like the popularity of the show really surged. And then also I was walking around with the beers. So that was a real high frequency Mo's sighting, I would say. Oh my gosh. Okay. Okay. We've talked a lot about the crazy things you had to do
每个人都在刷这部剧。这部剧的热度真的暴涨顶。而且我当时还留着那个大胡子到处走。所以那真的是莫兹出镜率极高的一段时期，我想可以说是这样的。天哪。好吧。好吧。我们已经聊了很多你不得不做那些疯狂事情的经历，
as Mo's that were sort of torturous. Was there any moment being Moe's that you had fun? Was there a scene, was there one moment that you really enjoyed? It was always fun. Like even when I was being tortured, it was always fun. Cause I really like, I revere actors in a very sort of childlike way.
作为莫兹，那些经历有点像折磨。在扮演莫兹的过程中，有没有哪个时刻你是觉得开心的？有没有哪场戏，有没有哪个瞬间是你真正享受的？其实一直都挺开心的。即使是在被折磨的时候，也总是开心的。因为我真的很喜欢——我以一种非常纯真、像小孩子一样的方式崇敬演员。
I fundamentally don't understand how actors do what you do. I find it to be the most difficult of all of the performing arts by far. It's so much harder than writing. I think it's harder than directing. And I really, that was really hammered home to me, even when I was doing this ridiculous site gag, and had to say a few words here and there. I was always like, God, I'm so much worse at this than I am in my head. Which is why I'm a writer. It's like what a writer is, right? I know what it should be. I just don't know how to actually do it myself.
我根本不理解演员是怎么做到你们那种表演的。我觉得这是所有表演艺术中最难的，远远超过其他。比写作难得多。我觉得比导演还要难。这一点真的深深印在了我的脑海里，即使我在做这个荒谬的视觉笑话，还不得不在这里和那里说几句台词的时候。我总是想，天哪，我在这方面比我在脑海里想象的要差远了。这就是为什么我只能当个编剧。这就是编剧的本质，对吧？我知道它应该是什么样子的。我只是不知道该怎么自己把它实际演出来。
So there were times when, for example, do you remember the episode where, of course you do, the episode where Jim and Pam are excited because Shrewd Farms has become a B&B. Yes. And they go and check in. It's the one where I run along the side of the car like a dog at the beginning, right?
所以有些时候，比如说，你还记得那一集吗？——当然记得，吉姆和帕姆很高兴，因为施鲁德农场变成了一家民宿。是的。然后他们去登记入住。就是我在开头像狗一样沿着车子旁边奔跑的那一集，对吧？
Yes. I want to mention quickly, Mike, for anybody, John Krasinski was not driving slow. I was in the car, and I remember that it was 100 degrees that day, because that's the day that John thought it would be really funny to prank me and put the car heater seat on because we weren't allowed to have the air conditioner for sound and I was like so hot. But then you were running next to the car.
是的。我想快点提一下，迈克，对任何人来说，约翰·卡拉辛斯基当时开得可不慢。当时我在车里，我记得那天温度高达100华氏度（约38摄氏度），因为那天约翰觉得捉弄我一定很有趣，他把汽车座椅加热器打开了，因为为了收音我们不允许开空调，我当时热得要命。但你当时在车旁边跑步。
So I thought, well, I can't complain about being hot because I mean, look at Mike out there, like running his hardest. And John was like going fast. I mean, I don't know how you did it. You were very fast. I don't know how you did that. You were very fast. I don't know how you did that. That was the hardest acting I've ever done.
所以我当时想，好吧，我不能抱怨天气热，因为——你看迈克在外面，跑得那么拼命。而且约翰开得很快。我是说，我不知道你是怎么做到的。你跑得非常快。我不知道你是怎么做到的。你跑得非常快。我不知道你是怎么做到的。那是我做过最难的表演。
And all I was doing is running because I was in those wool clothes and I was wearing those work boots and John was driving like 15 to 20 miles an hour on that dirt road and I had to keep up. But also I had to run up to the window, disappear behind the car and then run fast to catch up to the other side of the window.
我当时所做的就是奔跑，因为我穿着那些羊毛衣服，还穿着那些工作靴，而约翰在那条土路上以每小时15到20英里的速度开车，我必须跟上。而且我还必须跑到车窗旁，消失在车身后面，然后飞奔去追赶车窗的另一侧。
Exactly. And also you weren't allowed to use your arms. Yes. Your arms were like, so there was like a lack of momentum that you could create because you were only using your bottom half. I want to read to you what Dunderpedia, the fan website, how they explain Moe's running.
没错。而且你还不被允许摆动手臂。是的。你的手臂就像是——所以你无法产生那种动量，因为你只能靠下半身。我想读给你听听“Dunderpedia”——那个粉丝网站，他们是如何解释莫兹的奔跑的。
They say, Moe's proceeds to run away in his usual running with his arms swinging no higher than his waist style. I don't know where that came from. I like one of the early, one of the early Moses appearances. It was like, you know, Moses runs in to the, I think it was in the, in the initiation, like Moses runs into the room And I don't know why,
他们说，莫兹开始用他那标志性的奔跑姿势跑开，手臂摆动绝不超过腰部。我不知道那灵感是从哪来的。我很喜欢莫兹早期的几次出场之一。那就像是，你知道的，莫兹跑进，我想是在那个，在那个入会仪式里，莫兹跑进房间，我不知道为什么，
but I just did that really awkward run. That's not how I run when I'm running. I hope not. I just did that for some reason and then it just became the thing that Mo's does. But what Jen is saying is true though, because after I ran and caught up to the car, I then had to run past the car.
但我当时就做了那个非常别扭的跑步动作。我平时跑步可不是这样的。希望不是吧。我当时就莫名其妙地做了那个动作，然后这就成了莫兹的招牌动作。不过詹娜说的是真的，因为在我跑完并追上汽车之后，我接着还得从车旁跑过去。
I had to speed past it and run like a hundred yards all the way over to where the farmhouse was. And I knew I wasn't on camera anymore because obviously the cameras, what's interesting is not, is not, excuse me, what's interesting is not Mo's running anymore. What's interesting is Jim and Pam reacting to this weird dog person that just ran alongside their car, but they made me run all the way, like a hundred yards every single time. And we did like 11 takes of that.
我不得不加速冲过去，跑了一百码左右，一直跑到农舍所在的地方。我知道自己已经不在镜头里了，因为很显然，摄像机，有趣的地方已经不是，不是了，不好意思，有趣的地方不再是莫兹在跑步了。有趣的是吉姆和帕姆对这个刚刚从他们的车旁跑过的怪异狗人做出反应，但他们让我每次都一路跑，大概一百码。而且我们拍了大约11条。
And I've never been more sore in my life than I was the day after that. Cause I didn't know that I was gonna have to run a hundred, I was gonna have to run a dozen hundred yard sprints. You were like an Olympic contender. You like outran a car. Yeah.
我一生中从来没有像那次之后第二天那样酸痛过。因为我不知道我得跑一百码，我得跑十几次一百码的冲刺。你就像个奥运会选手。你居然跑赢了一辆车。对啊。
It was the, it's the most athletic I've ever been. I would say it's the most, the highest level of athletic achievement of my life. Well, we have it on camera. It's for all time. Forever. Forever documented. There's proof. There's proof that I used to be a good runner. But I'm sorry because you were gonna say something about
那是我，那是我有生以来最具运动能力的时候。可以说是我一生中运动成就的最高峰。好吧，我们把它拍下来了。这是永久的。永远的。永远被记录下来了。有证据。有证据证明我曾经是个优秀的跑步者。不过对不起，因为你刚才要说关于
that episode that you enjoyed. Yes. So there was a scene that I don't even know if it made it into the episode. I don't think it did. But there was a scene where Jim and Pam, in that episode, at night, Pam hears Dwight kind of moaning and sad because Angela has broken up with him, I think. And then in the morning, Dwight's gone. And Jim and Pam come down and are being— Moses serving them breakfast. Bacon! Tons of bacon! Just nothing but bacon. And it was actually the closest I ever came to having a scene. Because it was like a page
你很喜欢的某一集。是的。所以有一个场景，我甚至不知道它最终有没有剪进正片里。我觉得没有。但有一个场景是吉姆和帕姆在那一集里，在晚上，帕姆听到德怀特在哼哼唧唧、闷闷不乐，因为安吉拉跟他分手了，我想是这样。然后到了早上，德怀特不见了。吉姆和帕姆下楼来——莫兹在端茶倒水给他们。培根！大量的培根！全都是培根。这其实是我离演一场戏最近的一次。因为那就像是一页
of dialogue where I was serving you and you were saying, I think Jenna, you say like, Mo's, do you know where Dwight is? Or is he sad about Angela or something? And we actually had an exchange where I had to memorize lines and know what my cues were. And I remember thinking like I'm not this isn't what I'm doing is not per se good but I'm enjoying the process of learning what it's like to be an actor and to actually try to like be like be aware of the camera be be present in the scene like listen to what you're saying and respond with the lines that were written for me. And it was weirdly kind of thrilling. And I was like, this is never going to make it in. Like I, I'd worked at the show long enough to know that we didn't have time for this weird, dumb, Moe's, Jim, Pam scene. But, but I really did have fun doing it because it felt like,
台词，我要端着东西服侍你们，而你们在说，我想詹娜你当时说的是，莫兹，你知道德怀特在哪吗？还是说他是在为安吉拉伤心之类的？我们其实有一段对手戏，我必须背熟台词，知道我的cue点是什么。我记得当时想，我这演得其实并不是，这不是说我演得有多好，但我很享受学习当演员是什么感觉的过程，去真正尝试意识到摄像机的存在，在场景中保持专注，听你们在说什么，然后用为我写好的台词做出回应。这种感觉莫名其妙地有点让人兴奋。当时我想，这绝对会被剪掉。因为我，我在这个节目工作的时间够长了，我知道我们没有时间去拍这个奇怪、愚蠢的莫兹、吉姆和帕姆的场景。但是，我拍的时候真的很开心，因为我觉得，
I think it gave me a greater appreciation just for like what, how hard it is to do that. How hard it is to just be in a scene, have lines that you have to have memorized, and know how to say them properly and in an interesting way while there are cameras on you, while there's people in the room. It's just a very difficult skill. I think that the world of television and movies would be better if every writer were forced to act sometimes and if every actor were forced to direct and if every director were forced to write. Like if we all switched positions every once in a while, just to remind ourselves like the other skills
我觉得这让我对这件事情的难度有了更深的感激之情。要融入一个场景有多难，要把必须背熟的台词说好，在摄像机对着你、房间里有人的情况下，以正确且有趣的方式把台词说出来有多难。这真是一项非常困难的技能。我认为如果每个编剧有时都被迫去表演，如果每个演员都被迫去导演，如果每个导演都被迫去写作，电视和电影界将会变得更好。就像如果我们每隔一段时间就交换一次立场，只是为了提醒我们自己，制作电视艺术所涉及的其他技能，
that are involved in making TV art, each of them is so hard. It's so specific and so hard. So I really did like that. I liked acting in those scenes just as a way to like remind me of how difficult a skill it is. Now I have a question. Yeah. Because of your experience with Mo's and knowing
每一项都是那么难。它是如此具体且如此困难。所以我真的很喜欢那个。我喜欢在那些场景里演戏，只是把它当作一种提醒，提醒自己这是一项多么困难的技能。现在我有个问题。好的。鉴于你扮演莫兹的经历，以及了解
everything that would go into some of the physical comedy bits that you were asked to do, as a writer, does it ever get in your head when you come up with a really great gag? Do you think to yourself, oh no, I'm gonna have to put this actor through this horrible thing? And like, does it ever like affect your writing?
你需要完成的一些身体喜剧桥段背后的所有工作，作为一个编剧，当你想到一个非常精彩的包袱时，你心里会不会有所顾忌？你会不会想，哦不，我又要让这个演员经历这种可怕的事情了？这会不会影响你的写作？
It really does. And I have found myself talking to actors a lot and saying like, we have this idea for this silly thing. Are you cool with this? They always say yes. Like actors are incredibly adaptable people by and large. They're always happy to, or in my experience have been always happy to say like,
确实如此。我发现自己经常和演员交流，对他们说，我们对这个蠢事有个点子。你觉得这可以吗？他们总是说好。演员总体上是适应能力极强的群体。他们总是很高兴，或者以我的经验来看，总是很高兴地说，
oh yeah, that sounds fun. The one time I didn't do this and I wish I had, although it was fine, nothing bad happened, but we wrote it, there was a scene in the show, The Good Place that I created where William Jackson Harper played a character who was sort of a, he was a, he's sort of a tortured soul. He wants to be sort of morally perfect.
哦，是的，听起来挺有意思的。有一次我没有这么做，但我希望自己当时做了，虽然结果也挺好，没发生什么坏事，但我们写过，我创作的剧集《善地》里有一场戏，威廉·杰克逊·哈珀饰演一个角色，他有点像一个饱受折磨的灵魂。他希望自己在道德上近乎完美。
And he believes that such a thing is possible. And there's an episode where he's sort of going through an existential crisis. And he's just sort of walking around lost in a daze. And he like, he goes into, he's like walking around and some sprinklers go off and they just soak him. And he just kind of stands there and just gets soaked by the sprinklers. And then he just kind of like takes his shirt off and just kind of keeps walking.
他相信这种事情是可能的。有一集他正在经历某种存在主义危机。他只是四处游荡，迷茫得像在梦游。然后他走进，他四处走动，一些洒水器突然喷水，把他淋得透湿。他就站在那里，任由洒水器把他浇透。然后他随手脱掉衬衫，继续往前走。
And then you cut to him and he's in a grocery store shopping shirtless. And then, excuse me. And then like a woman comes over and is like, sir, you have to wear a shirt in here. And he just grabs like a shirt off a rack and just puts it on and smiles and keeps walking. And it turns out that William Jackson Harper is like, cut, like he's like a very like physically fit person, which I did not know.
镜头一转，他光着膀子在杂货店购物。然后，不好意思。接着有个女人走过来，像是在说，先生，你在这里必须穿上衬衫。他随手从货架上抓起一件衬衫穿上，微笑着继续往前走。结果威廉·杰克逊·哈珀的身材非常棒，卡特——我是说他身材非常好，而我之前并不知道。
Like that, I had never seen him with his shirt off before he shot that scene. But him taking his shirt off caused the internet to like explode because it was like oh my god the like the dorky philosophy professor guy is also jacked and And I mean it was he was only good for him like I Everybody was happy with the result, but it I was like oh my god I never asked him if it was okay that I wrote this thing where he takes his shirt off.
就像那样，在我拍那场戏之前，我从来没见过他光着膀子的样子。但他脱掉衬衫让互联网瞬间炸锅了，因为大家都在想，天哪，那个书呆子哲学教授居然也有一身肌肉。我的意思是，这结果对他很好，每个人都对结果很满意，但我当时想，天哪，我从来没问过他，我写了这么一个让他脱衣服的桥段，他是不是觉得可以。
Like I should ask actors that more. Like I should say, are you okay with this? And I think if there were, it's a gendered thing in a way it shouldn't be, right? Like if it, obviously if there had, if it had been a woman, I would never in a billion years have written any scene where a woman disro would never in a billion years have written any scene where a woman disrobes in any way without clearing it with her first.
我觉得我以后应该多问问演员这些。我应该说，你觉得这样可以吗？我觉得如果有的话，从某种程度上讲这是一个带有性别色彩的问题，虽然本不该如此。如果，很明显如果是换成一个女性，我绝不会在任何情况下写出任何让女性脱衣服的戏份，在没有事先跟她沟通好的情况下绝不会。
There would have been a million discussions and meetings and whatever, and it didn't occur to me that a man might also be uncomfortable with that. And so I remember thinking like, I'm so happy that it was okay, that he was okay with it, that whatever. But I also, again, like, and this weirdly comes from playing Moe's and all the ridiculous, I had to pick up cow patties and throw them at Rainn Wilson and do all sorts of like humiliating things. No one ever asked me if I was okay with any of it. And it, I do think that it's, those conversations should happen more often, even when you don't think there will be any problem with this. I think there should be generally more communication between writers and directors and actors to just say like, Hey, just want to make sure
这中间会有无数次的讨论、会议以及各种安排，而我当时居然没有想到男人对这种事也可能会感到不自在。所以我记得当时想，太好了，他觉得没问题，他能接受，不管怎样。但我又回想起，而且这奇怪地源于扮演莫斯以及所有那些荒谬的经历，我不得不捡起牛粪扔向雷恩·威尔逊，还要做各种各样羞辱人的事情。从来没有人问过我是否能接受这些。确实，我觉得这些对话应该更频繁地发生，即使你觉得不会有任何问题。我觉得编剧、导演和演员之间总体上应该有更多的沟通，只是说，嘿，我只是想确认一下
you're cool with this. If you're not, it's totally okay, we can write something else. So anyway, I don't know if that answers your question or not. But well, it's really interesting because as an actor, I feel like this comes up a lot in television because you agree to play a character, but you don't know what is going to be written about your character beyond the pilot episode. And so there could be years and years and years of stories and they are a surprise to the actor every week. And so with a movie, well, I can see the movie script if there's like three weird sex scenes
你对这个没意见吧。如果你觉得不行，完全没关系，我们可以写别的。总之，我不知道这算不算回答了你的问题。不过，这真的很有趣，因为作为演员，我觉得电视里经常出现这种情况，因为你同意扮演一个角色，但除了试播集之外，你并不知道关于你的角色以后会写出什么内容。所以可能会有长年累月的剧情，而这些剧情每周对演员来说都是一个惊喜。相比之下，如果是电影，我可以看电影剧本，如果有三场奇怪的床戏
or like a weird scene that makes me uncomfortable, I can just say, oh, this isn't the part for me. Right, you know the whole story. Yeah, I know everything that's being asked of me when I accept that movie role. But when you accept a television role, you don't know what's going to be asked of you. And I've always thought that that communication, you know, this came up on our
或者某个让我感到不舒服的奇怪场景，我可以直接说，哦，这个角色不适合我。没错，你知道整个故事。对，当我接受那个电影角色时，我知道被要求做的一切。但当你接受一个电视剧角色时，你不知道自己会被要求做什么。而且我一直认为这种沟通，你知道，这在我们
show later when they came up with the really funny idea that Pam would have a male lactation consultant who would be massaging her breasts in front of Jim and that Pam and the lactation consultant would find this very clinical and that Jim was trying to also find it clinical. Trying to be cool. Yeah, but was also like, this handsome man is massaging my wife's breasts right now. And I remember they came up to me and said, we think this is really funny, but we imagine that it would be weird for you to have a total stranger that you met that day come
剧的后期也出现过，当时他们想出了一个非常有趣的桥段，就是潘有一个男催乳师，当着吉姆的面按摩她的胸部，而潘和催乳师觉得这非常医疗化，吉姆也试图将其视为医疗行为。努力表现得很酷。是的，但心里也在想，这个帅哥现在正在按摩我老婆的胸部。我记得他们走过来对我说，我们觉得这非常搞笑，但我们猜你可能会觉得，让一个当天刚认识的陌生人来做这件事会觉得很奇怪
and handle your breasts and the joke only works if they're actually touching your breasts. So what if your fiance Lee played the role and then it's someone who's already massaging your breasts, massaging your breasts. And I was like, well, he does massage them, so that is true. And so it was great. So then it was just weird for John. Yeah, then it was just weird for everyone else because we were super comfortable. Well, I think that's, first of all, good for them for obviously bringing that up,
然后处理你的胸部，这个笑话只有在他们真的碰到你的胸部时才成立。所以如果你未婚夫李扮演这个角色，然后是一个已经在给你按摩胸部、按摩胸部的人呢？当时我就想，嗯，他确实帮我按摩，所以这是真的。所以这太棒了。然后对约翰来说就变得很诡异了。对，然后对其他人来说也很诡异，因为我们超级自在。嗯，首先我觉得，他们能把这个提出来，对他们来说当然很好，
but also like that, there is an enormous leap of faith that you're taking as an actor when you sign onto a TV show, right? You're really like, you're using a very small amount of data, which is usually like a pilot script, and maybe a meeting with the show creator or the showrunner, and you're extrapolating over potentially 10 years and 200 episodes of like, am I putting my faith and trust in this person and is it gonna be rewarded or are there gonna be constant battles and fights about creative directions
但同时这也意味着，你作为一名演员，在签约一部电视剧时，实际上是进行了一场豪赌，对吧？你真的就像是，你只能利用极少的数据，通常也就是试播集剧本，或许还有跟剧集主创或运作人的会面，然后你要在可能长达10年、共200集的跨度下去推测：我是在把我的信任托付给这个人吗？这份信任会有回报吗？还是说我们会在创作方向上产生源源不断的争执和对抗，
and things that they ask me to do that. And this is part of why being an actor I think is so difficult is you only, you're only advocate is yourself. Like you don't have, you know, you maybe have an agent or a manager who can have your back in those moments, but it's like this idea of like the quote difficult actor end quote. Like I think that is a horrible misnomer
以及他们要求我去做的事情。这也是为什么我觉得当演员这么难的一部分原因，因为你唯一的代言人只有你自己。比如你没有，你知道的，你或许有个经纪人或经理能在那些时刻为你撑腰，但这就好比“所谓的‘难搞演员’”这种观念。我觉得这是一个极其糟糕的误称，
that has come from now 80 years of actors being getting a new script every week and not having any idea what's in it. And those ideas coming from people who maybe haven't run a bunch of things by them and just being like, oh man, now I got to do this this week. And the range of how it can make an actor feel uncomfortable is enormous. It can be anything from like a strange man
它源于过去80年来演员每周都能拿到新剧本却完全不知道里面写了什么的情况。而这些想法来自于那些可能并没有跟他们商量过各种事情的人，他们只会觉得：天哪，我这周得把这事儿办了。这种状况能让演员感到多么不舒服，其程度和范围是极其巨大的。它可能任何事都包括，比如一个陌生男子
has to massage parts of your body that you might not want that person to massage, all the way to just creative decisions about the character, the choices the character makes, things that the character does that you don't agree with. Like, it's just really hard. It's a very difficult thing. And the chance for it to go sideways is enormous. So the more communication there is between writers and actors, the better. To bring this full circle, that's another thing
不得不按摩你身体的某些部位，而你可能并不想让那个人按摩；一直到仅仅是关于角色的创作决定、角色做出的选择、以及角色所做的一些你并不认同的事情。总之这真的很艰难。这是一件非常困难的事。事情走向偏离正轨的可能性巨大无比。所以编剧和演员之间的沟通越多越好。把话题绕回来，这也是另一件事，
that I remember thinking I could attribute to SNL a little bit with Greg because Greg worked there. At SNL, like everybody does everything. Writers act and actors write, and it's very like community theater kind of feeling. And there's no division between actors and writers really at all. Like it's all one big hodgepodge. And that was Greg's whole theory was like,
我记得这可以稍微归功于周六夜现场（SNL），因为格雷格在那里工作过。在SNL，每个人都会做所有事。编剧会去表演，演员也会写剧本，感觉非常像社区剧场。演员和编剧之间真的没有任何隔阂。一切就像是一个巨大的大杂烩。而这正是格雷格的整个理论，即：
let's break down these artificial barriers between the writers and the actors. That's why he wanted Mindy and BJ and Paul to act in the show. It's why he gave the season two finale where Jim and Pam, where Jim tells Pam that he likes her or is in love with her and that they kiss for the first time. Steve wrote that. He gave that to Steve. That's traditionally the kind of thing that he would write or a co-EP trusted writer would write that script. But Greg saw the big picture and he understood fundamentally that the more there was that we he broke down the divisions between writers and actors the healthier the organism of the show would be
让我们打破编剧和演员之间这些人工筑起的壁垒。这就是为什么他想让明迪、BJ和保罗在剧中表演。这也是为什么他把第二季季终集交给了史威（Steve），在这一集中，吉姆告诉帕姆他喜欢她或者爱上了她，并且他们第一次接吻。史蒂夫写了那一集。他把这个交给了史蒂夫。传统上，这种情节应该由他自己或者某个受信任的合作执行制片人来写。但格雷格看到了大局，他从根本上理解到，我们越是打破编剧和演员之间的隔阂，剧集这个有机体就会越健康，
and he was totally right. So true. I mean Jenna and I have talked about that a lot on this podcast. Other shows that we have done since The Office. I did a guest star on a show and the writers room was in New York and we filmed in LA. And I thought, wow, they never meet the writers. They never interact with them at all. And it's just been such an interesting and wonderful perspective to look back at how fortunate we were to have that sort of creative collaboration as our biggest job in our life.
而他是完全正确的。确实如此。我是说，珍娜和我在这档播客里经常讨论这个。我们离开《办公室》之后拍的其他剧。我在一部剧里客串过，当时编剧室在纽约，而我们在洛杉矶拍摄。我想，哇，他们永远见不到编剧。他们跟编剧完全没有任何互动。回想起来，我们能把这种创意合作作为我们生平最大的工作，是多么的幸运，这真是一个非常有趣且美妙的视角。
I've bounced up to writers on sets at other jobs thinking that the way we had it on the office was normal and they seem terrified to speak to me. They are terrified that I am talking to them. They are afraid to say anything. I'll be like, hey, what's up? What do you think, like next week, what do you think is gonna be like,
我在其他片场也曾跑去找编剧聊天，以为我们在《办公室》里的那种模式是常态，结果他们看起来好像吓得不敢跟我说话。他们害怕我在跟他们讲话。他们害怕说任何话。我会说：嘿，最近怎么样？你觉得接下来一周，会是什么样的，
how's this story gonna play out? And they're like, I next week, what do you think is going to be like, how's this story going to play out? And they're like, I don't want to speak to you. The first time I did a multicam after the office, because I'd never done a multicam, all the writers were like huddled in a corner, you know, like we're filming. It's like filming a one act play. And they're all in the corner because I knew this joke wasn't working. And I had like a few ideas. So I went up to the huddle and I was like, hey guys, I got like a two or three pitches.
这个故事会怎么发展？然后他们就会说：我……等下周，会是什么样的，这个故事会怎么发展？然后他们就像是：我不想跟你说话。我在拍完《办公室》后第一次拍多机位情景喜剧，因为我以前从没拍过多机位，所有的编剧都缩在一个角落里，你知道的，就像我们在拍戏一样。这就好比在排演一幕剧。他们全都缩在角落里，因为我知道这个笑话不太灵。而且我有一些想法。于是我朝那个小圈子走过去，说道：嘿，伙计们，我有两三个点子。
And they were like, what? It was like record scratch. Yeah, I know. And again, Greg's ethos was, Greg's ethos in a nutshell is best idea wins. And he doesn't care whether the best idea comes from a writer, an actor, a director, an accountant, a random person on the street who happens to walk by
然后他们的反应是：啊？那感觉就像唱片刮擦声一样戛然而止。对，我懂。再说一次，格雷格的精神内核是：格雷格精神的精髓就在于——最好的创意胜出。他才不在乎这个最好的创意是来自编剧、演员、导演、会计，还是刚好路过、
at the right moment and has a good pitch. It was just, why would we not take the best idea? And so that fostered that sense of, everybody give us all your ideas. Let's put all of the ideas into a pot and pick the best one. And that is very frequently, sadly, not how it works on other shows. And it's a shame because, you know,
在关键时刻碰巧有个好点子的街头路人。道理很简单：我们为什么不采纳最好的点子呢？因此，这就培养了这样一种氛围：每个人都把你们所有的点子拿出来。我们把所有的点子都放进一个池子里，然后选出最好的一个。不幸的是，在其他剧组里，这通常并不是运作方式，这真的很遗憾，因为，你知道的，
there were times when we would be battling about something in the edit bay about an episode and that he'd have two alts and he would say, which one do you like? And all of the writers would choose version A and he would go like, and then he would call in the accounting department. Yeah.
有时候我们在剪辑室里为了一集的内容争论不休，他有两个备选方案，然后他会问：你喜欢哪一个？所有的编剧都会选择A版本，而他的反应会是：然后他把会计部门的人叫了进来。对。
And he'd be like, which one do you like? The real accounting. The actual accountants, yeah. Yes, not you and Oscar. Yeah, not he'd be like, which one do you like? The real accountants. The actual accountants. Yeah. Yes. Not you and Oscar. Yeah, not me and Brian and Oscar. And he would go, which one do you like? And they would say, we like B. And he's like, Yeah, I think B is better. And it drove us crazy sometimes. But he was like, you're not the audience. You're
然后他会问：你们喜欢哪一个？真正的会计。真正的会计，对。是的，不是你和奥斯卡。对，不是我、布莱恩和奥斯卡。然后他会问：你们喜欢哪一个？他们会说：我们喜欢B。然后他就说：对，我觉得B更好。这有时把我们气个半死。但他会说：你们不是观众。你们是
professional comedy writers. Like, of course, you're gonna like this weird offbeat thing that we did. You know what the best example of this is? So Jim's proposal to Pam at the gas station, right? So three versions, I don't know if you remember this, Jenna, we had three versions. One of them was the car pulls over, the camera is across the street
职业喜剧编剧。所以，你们当然会喜欢我们做的这种古怪、离经叛道的东西。你知道这最好的例子是什么吗？就是吉姆在加油站向帕姆求婚的那一幕，对吧？所以有三个版本，我不知道你还记不记得，珍娜，我们当时有三个版本。其中一个是车子停下，摄像机在街对面，
and is shooting super long lens and all you hear is traffic whizzing by in the foreground and you can't hear, they're not mic'd in this version, the sound was off. So you saw Jim walk up and you saw Pam and then ha ha and then all of a sudden they're talking you don't know what they're saying, Jim gets down on one knee, Pam reacts, and then they hug and they kiss and it's over. And second version was, or the final version was like very traditionally shot. Like you were right with them in the gas station,
用超长焦镜头拍摄，你听到的只有前景中呼啸而过的车流声，你听不到，在这个版本里他们没有戴无线麦，声音是关掉的。所以你看到吉姆走过来，你看到了帕姆，然后哈哈，突然间他们在交谈，你根本不知道他们在说什么，吉姆单膝下跪，帕姆做出反应，接着他们拥抱、亲吻，然后就结束了。第二个版本是，或者说最终版是按照非常传统的方式拍摄的。就像你和他们一起在加油站里一样，
sort of looking in a classic TV coverage. And you could still hear traffic whizzing by in the background, but you couldn't really see it. And the cameras are right up close. And then there was a sort of intermediate version where you were a little bit further away, but you could hear what they were saying and he screened all three of them and the, the one that was where the camera was super far away and you couldn't hear a word gave me like the greatest goosebump feeling of my life.
有点像经典电视剧镜头的视角。你仍然能听到背景里汽车呼啸而过的声音，但你其实看不到车。摄像机就架在很近的地方。然后还有个折中版本，就是你离得稍微远一点，但你能听清他们在说什么。他把这三个版本都放映了，其中那个摄像机离得超级远、你一个字也听不清的版本，给我带来了我一生中最震撼的鸡皮疙瘩般的感受。
Like I was like, that's so beautiful. It's so perfect for the show. It reminded me of the scene in the British office where Tim takes off his mic and goes in and talks to Dawn. That was the sort of model of it where, and you don't hear what they're saying. And then he comes back out and grabs the mic and says, she said, no, by the way, and, and it's terrible and sad. Um, and I was like, well, that's, that's a home run. That's like the most beautiful. It's so perfect. It's the most beautiful thing ever. And he was like, yeah, we're not using that version. And I was like, well, that's a home run. That's like the most beautiful, it's so perfect, it's the most beautiful thing ever.
当时我觉得，这太美了。太适合这部剧了。它让我想起了英国版《办公室》里的那个场景：蒂姆摘下麦克风，走进去跟唐说话。那种模式大概就是这样，你听不到他们在说什么。然后他走出来，抓起麦克风说：顺便说一句，她说不。而且这个结果糟糕又伤感。嗯，当时我就想，哇，这绝对是个本垒打。这简直太美了。太完美了。这是有史以来最美妙的东西。而他的反应却是：嗯，我们不用那个版本。而我的反应则是：哇，这绝对是个本垒打。这简直太美了。太完美了。这是有史以来最美妙的东西。
And he was like, yeah, we're not using that version. And I was like, why? And he was like, because this is a moment that fans of the show have been waiting for, for five, six years, whatever it was. And it's just fundamentally not fair to deny them the ability to hear Jim say, will you marry me?
而他的反应却是：嗯，我们不用那个版本。我问：为什么？他说：因为这是这部剧的粉丝们等待了五年、六年，无论具体多久的一个重要时刻。而剥夺他们听到吉姆说“你愿意嫁给我吗”的权利，从根本上来说是不公平的。
It's just mean. It's like, and this might be the most sort of like beautiful, artistic, you know, like highfalutin version. But if, if what, what are we doing if we're denying fans the ability to hear Jim say, will you marry me? And hear Pam say, yes, that's just cruel. And I always fought him on all of those decisions and he was always right.
这太残忍了。这就像是，这或许是最具艺术感、最高雅的版本。但是，如果我们剥夺了粉丝们听到吉姆说“你愿意嫁给我吗”以及听到帕姆说“我愿意”的权利，那我们到底在干什么？这简直太残酷了。我一直在所有这些决定上跟他争执，而他每一次都是对的。
Just like at the end of the day, I was like, of course, of course you need to hear, will you marry me? Yes, like that's such a foundational moment in the history of the show. And so he had that thing of like, let's develop and explore every possible idea. Let's walk down every path. Let's pull every name out of the hat.
就像到了最后一天，我就想，当然，你当然需要听到“你愿意嫁给我吗？”是的，这是节目历史上非常基础的一个时刻。所以他当时的想法就是，我们要开发和探讨每一种可能的主意。我们要尝试每一条路径。我们要从帽子里抽出每一个名字。
And at the end of the day, we will choose the one that is the best for the show, not the one that's loved the most by the people who work on the show or the writers who write things or anything else. just what is the best thing for the show. And that's why the show over the course of its decade long run had such an integrity to it, I think it's because it was always the decisions were always made in terms of what's best for the show, not not what a bunch of like jaded writers thought would be the coolest thing or something like that.
而归根结底，我们会选择对节目最好的那一个，而不是节目组里的人或者写剧本的编剧们最喜欢的那一个，或者其他什么。只选对节目最好的东西。这就是为什么这部剧在其长达十年的播出过程中始终保持着那种完整性，我认为这是因为它的决策总是根据什么对节目最好来做出，而不是根据一群厌世的编剧认为最酷的事情或其他类似的事情来决定。
Do you wanna ask Mike about the Christmas lights? Oh yeah, I do. This is such a hard pivot. But we, okay, so in the first Christmas episode, which, oh my God, I just love that episode so much, I can watch it every year. It's almost like, what do you like to watch at the holidays? Oh, that Christmas vacation with Chevy Chase.
你想问迈克关于圣诞彩灯的事吗？哦，对，我想问。这是一个非常生硬的转折。但是我们，好吧，所以在第一集圣诞特辑里，哦天哪，我太喜欢那一集了，我每年都可以看。这就有点像，你在假期喜欢看什么？哦，切维·切斯的那个《疯狂圣诞假期》。
I like to watch the very first Christmas episode. The office Christmas, Yankee swap, yeah. I have had a Yankee swap party for years inspired by that episode. I love everything about it. So there was this moment that we heard was inspired by your real life where when they put up the Christmas tree,
我喜欢看第一集圣诞特辑。办公室圣诞节，洋基换礼，对。受那一集的启发，我举办了好几年的洋基换礼派对。我喜欢关于它的一切。所以我们听说有这样一个时刻是受到你真实生活的启发，当时他们挂上圣诞树时，
the tiny, tiny Christmas lights, and Angela's so mad at Phyllis, she's so pissed off. And we heard that was like actually based on something in your life. Was, is that true? And were there other moments like that, like things that were in your life that made it into the show?
那些极小极小的圣诞彩灯，安吉拉对菲利斯生气极了，她气炸了。我们听说那其实是根据你生活中的某件事改编的。是吗，这是真的吗？还有其他类似这样的时刻吗，比如你生活中的事被搬进了节目里？
Totally true. My first Christmas in LA, the show. Totally true. My first Christmas in LA, my then fiance, now wife, JJ and I got our first tree as cohabitants and we were so excited. We both love Christmas. We love like decorating the tree. We love everything and we bought the tree and we took it home.
完全是真的。我在洛杉矶过的第一个圣诞节，这部剧。完全是真的。我在洛杉矶过的第一个圣诞节，我当时的未婚妻、现在的妻子JJ和我，我们作为同居者买下了第一棵树，我们当时兴奋极了。我们都喜欢圣诞节。我们喜欢装饰圣诞树。我们喜欢一切，我们买下树，然后把它带回家。
We put it up and we played Christmas music and we played Christmas music. In my house growing up, you always did only white lights. I don't know why. That was what our family preferred. JJ had been like, I like the big colored ones. They're so cheery and happy. I, for some reason, won the argument. I don't know why, but I was like,
我们把它立起来，放起了圣诞音乐，我们放起了圣诞音乐。在我从小长大的家里，你们总是只用白灯。我不知道为什么。那是我们家偏爱的方式。JJ曾说过，我喜欢五颜六色的大彩灯。它们看起来真欢快、真开心。由于某种原因，我赢了这场争论。我不知道为什么，但我当时就想，
trust me, it looks great. I went and bought those little tiny white lights and I very carefully strung them around the tree and everything. And then we like were playing Christmas music and it was like a big countdown and I turned them on and you absolutely could not see any of them. They were the saddest, the least, the least. It was the opposite of the Rockefeller Center Christmas tree lighting. And I was immediately humiliated and I turned and my wife was just laughing at me so hard. Like just what a complete failure this was.
相信我，这看起来棒极了。我跑去买那些微型小白灯，然后非常小心地把它们串在树上等等。然后我们就像在放圣诞音乐，就像在倒计时一样，我把它们打开了，结果你绝对一个也看不见。它们是最令人悲伤、最稀疏、最……这简直是洛克菲勒中心圣诞树点灯仪式的反面。我当时立刻就感到丢脸极了，我转过身，我妻子正笑得前仰后合。就觉得这彻底失败得太彻底了。
And I immediately went out and went to the drugstore and bought big colored lights and came home and we strung them up. So, but I remember that feeling and like that episode is so much about like expectation versus reality. And so I was like, Oh, that would be a good like little metaphor for what's about to happen to Michael Scott when he gets the Phyllis's oven mitt. So I just, I put it in as like Greg was so into, and the show was so into those
我立刻跑出去去了药妆店，买了大彩灯回家，然后我们把它们串上了。所以，但我记得那种感觉，那一集讲的很大程度上是关于期望与现实的落差。所以我当时就想，哦，这对于迈克·斯科特拿到菲利斯烤箱隔热手套时即将遭遇的一切来说，会是一个很好的隐喻。所以我把它加了进去，因为格雷格非常热衷于，而且这部剧非常热衷于那些
tiny, tiny, tiny observable moments of real life. And so I thought, well, that makes perfect sense. And my favorite thing about that is after they turn the lights on and Michael goes, not great, there's a quick pan to Angela who just looks angrier than she has ever looked in her entire life. I know. That episode gave me a full headache because I was just always so angry. Scowling, just scowling with everybody. Yeah, I mean, so much of what happened in those first, especially in the first season and a half, you know, seasons one and two, so much of that stuff was real observation, like, about people's lives.
现实生活中微乎其微、可被观察到的瞬间。所以我想，这太合情合理了。我最喜欢的一点是，在他们打开灯、迈克说“不太妙”之后，镜头迅速切到了安吉拉，她看起来比她一生中任何时候都要生气。我知道。那一集让我头痛欲裂，因为我总是那么生气。怒目而视，就是和所有人一起怒目而视。是的，我的意思是，在前几季中发生的事情，尤其是第一季和第一季半（你知道的，第一季和第二季），其中很多内容都是真实的观察，比如关于人们的生活。
Like, all of the gifts in that, that I invented for, this was another great writing lesson that came from that episode. So in my original version, the person who had Angela, maybe, no, Oscar had Creed. Who had, who popped? Toby, Toby had, Toby, right, right. So Toby in the original version had a talking head
就像，我在那里面发明的所有礼物，这是那一集带来的又一个极好的写作课。所以在我的最初版本里，抽到安吉拉的人，也许，不对，奥斯卡抽到了克里德。谁抽到了？托比，托比抽到了，托比，对，没错。所以托比在最初的版本里有一个独白镜头，
where he was like, I don't know a lot about Angela. I know that she's religious. So I bought her this book. And the book was one of those sort of religious adjacent self-help books, you know, like sort of like leading a spiritual life or something. It's one of those kind of hokey books. And Greg was like, I don't think that he should give her that book because we already know that Angela has that tendency or leans in that direction. And so you're not the audience isn't getting any new information. And I was like, All right, well, well, like, what could it be? And then someone might been Greg, pitched that thing of a poster of babies who are dressed like adults. And nobody could understand why,
他在镜头前说，我对安吉拉了解不多。我知道她很虔诚。所以我给她买这本书。那本书是那种与宗教沾边的自助书之一，你知道的，有点像引领精神生活之类的。那是那种老掉牙的书之一。格雷格说，我觉得他不应该送她那本书，因为我们已经知道安吉拉有那种倾向或者倾向于那个方向。所以你没有——观众没有获得任何新信息。我说，好吧，那会是什么呢？然后有人——可能是格雷格——提出了一个点子，是一张把婴儿打扮成大人样子的海报。没有人能理解为什么，
but it was the perfect thing. It was just that perfect thing that it was like, you're learning more about Angela, right? You got a new piece of information about her character, but it's still very much in keeping with what we already know about her. And then that poster became like basis of like four other stories over the course of the show.
但这就是完美的东西。它就是那种完美的东西，就像是，你在更多地了解安吉拉，对吧？你得到了关于她角色的新信息，但它仍然非常符合我们对她的既有认知。然后那张海报在节目播出的过程中成了其他四个故事的基础。
Oh yeah, it became a huge source of contention between Angela and Oscar, because she hung it by her desk. And then Oscar had to wear it as a shirt. Yeah. Well, Angela in real life really likes animals who are dressed in costumes of other animals. I mean. It's very similar.
哦，是的，它成了安吉拉和奥斯卡之间的一大争端源头，因为她把它挂在办公桌旁。然后奥斯卡不得不把它穿成一件衬衫。是的。嗯，安吉拉在现实生活中真的很喜欢穿着其他动物服装的动物。我是说。这非常相似。
It's very similar to liking babies dressed as adults, I think. I mean, animals dressed as anything, really. Like if on Halloween you dress your dog as a hot dog, I'm gonna be like, oh my gosh! Your dog's a hot dog! So we have two dogs, and this year they were ketchup and mustard. Ah, I love it!
我觉得这和喜欢打扮成大人的婴儿非常相似。我的意思是，打扮成任何东西的动物，真的。就像万圣节如果你把你的狗打扮成热狗，我会说，哦天哪！你的狗是个热狗！所以我们养了两只狗，今年它们一个是番茄酱，一个是黄芥末。啊，我太喜欢了！
Oh, I would love to see a picture of that. That lights up Angela's life. It really does. So wait, animals dressed like other animals, you mean like a dog dressed like a cow or like a- Oh yeah, or like a teddy bear, but it has like a bunny hat. Yeah, I know why.
哦，我很想看一张那样的照片。那能点亮安吉拉的生活。确实如此。等等，打扮成其他动物的动物，你的意思是像一头打扮成奶牛的狗或者像一个——哦，是的，或者像一只泰迪熊，但它戴着一顶小兔子帽子。对，我懂为什么。
I don't know why. Mike, thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies today. This was such a treat. We want to tell people that you wrote a book. Yes. And the book is called How to be Perfect. It comes out on January 25th. Tell us about it.
我不知道为什么。迈克，非常感谢你今天来到“办公室女士”播客。这真是一次极好的享受。我们要告诉大家你写了一本书。是的。这本书叫《如何做到完美》（How to be Perfect）。它将于1月25日出版。给我们讲讲吧。
So this book came out of the show, The Good Place that I created, which was about, if you haven't seen it, it's very hard to explain it in one sentence, but it's essentially, I pitched it as a show about what it means to be a good person. And for the show, I read a lot of ethics and philosophy by a lot of very old, boring people. And I thought, I had this thought while I was researching it, which was that these people have such good ideas
所以这本书源自我创作的剧集《善地》（The Good Place），如果你没看过的话，它很难用一句话解释清楚，但本质上，我把它推销为一部关于“成为一个好人意味着什么”的剧。为了这部剧，我读了许多年迈、无聊的人写的关于伦理学和哲学的书。我想，我在研究时有了这样一个想法，那就是这些人有如此好的想法，
for how to be better people. Like, it's all of these ethical theories and this moral philosophy is like, it's like a how-to guide for like living a good life and being a good person on earth, but their writing is so tortured and boring that no one wants to read it. So maybe I could write a version where I sort of try to explain as best as I can what their theories are,
关于如何成为更好的人。比如，所有这些伦理理论和道德哲学，它就像是一本如何在地球上过上好生活、做一个好人的“操作指南”，但他们的文笔是如此痛苦和无聊，以至于没有人想读它。所以也许我可以写一个版本，我试着用我所能做到的最好方式去解释他们的理论，
but in a way that doesn't give you a tension headache and make you sleepy. So that's what it is. It's a summary of a lot of different theories and moral philosophy. The way that the book is organized is I pose a bunch of boring questions or mundane questions that face us every day. Like, if my friend bought an ugly shirt and says, what do you think of my shirt? Is it okay to lie to her? Or, or can you or can you or do you have to tell the truth? And so it's questions like that, that are just things that come up in everyday life. And then I try to explain what like different moral philosophers
但这种方式不会让你太阳穴抽痛、昏昏欲睡。所以这就是这本书的内容。它是对许多不同理论和道德哲学的总结。这本书的组织方式是我提出了每天都会面临的一堆无聊或世俗的问题。比如，如果我的朋友买了一件丑陋的衬衫并问：“你觉得我的衬衫怎么样？”对她说谎可以吗？或者，或者你可以——或者你可以——或者你必须说实话吗？所以它是诸如此类的问题，只是一些日常生活中出现的事情。然后我试着解释不同的道德哲学家，
and ethicists would say about those questions. So that's the idea. And it's on sale January, it's on sale now, you can buy it now from any online bookstore that you prefer. And also all of the proceeds are going to charity. So you can buy it and know that you're doing something good in the world by having money go to charity. Oh, I love that. Just by buying the book, I am being a good person. That's right. That's the idea, yeah. So you're really setting me up to succeed.
和伦理学家会对这些问题说些什么。这就是这个想法。它将于1月开售，现在已经开售了，你可以从你喜欢的任何在线书店购买。而且所有的收益都将捐给慈善机构。所以你买下它，就会知道通过把钱捐给慈善机构，你正在世界上做一件好事。哦，我太喜欢这个了。只要买这本书，我就是在做一个好人。没错。就是这个主意，是的。所以你真的在为我的成功铺路。
I know. I like it. I like it too. You know right away that you've made the world a slightly better place just by buying the book. It's that easy. It's that easy to be a good person. I love it. Well, this is what Mindy Kaling had to say about your book. She said,
我知道。我喜欢。我也很喜欢。你马上就会知道，仅仅通过买这本书，你就让世界变得稍微美好了那么一点点。就这么简单。做一个好人就是这么简单。我太喜欢了。好吧，这就是明迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）对你的书的评价。她说：
As someone who worries that a deep dive into morality will ruin my fun and problematic life, I was certain this book wouldn't be for me. Boy, was I wrong. It's so brilliant and funny and warmly written, you don't realize you're becoming a better person just by reading it. Yes, it was very nice of her to blurb the book. Her blurb is actually the one that made the cover, which I don't think I've told her yet. Cover blurb.
“作为一个担心深入探究道德会毁掉我有趣而问题重重的生活的人，我曾确信这本书不适合我。天哪，我大错特错了。它是如此才华横溢、妙趣横生且充满温情，以至于你甚至没有意识到，仅仅通过阅读它，你就在成为一个更好的人。”是的，她为这本书写封底推荐语真是太好了。她的推荐语实际上成了封面上的那一句，我想我还没告诉过她呢。封面推荐。
Oh, cover blurb. I found it online. That's fancy blurb right there. Yeah. Well, I'm so excited to read it. Yes, I have ordered my copy and Angela has too and we're gonna get them and Mike, thank you because I, well I'm a huge fan of your Twitter as well. Yeah. I feel like you're very, very good at taking complex ideas or thoughts and making them really digestible
哦，封面推荐语。我在网上看到了。那可是高级推荐语啊。是的。嗯，我太兴奋想读它了。是的，我已经订购了我的副本，安吉拉也订了，我们马上就能拿到了。迈克，谢谢你，因为我——好吧，我也是你推特（Twitter）的超级粉丝。是的。我觉得你非常擅长将复杂的想法或思想变得非常容易理解，
and entertaining, you're also very good at breaking down baseball statistics. Yes, I have found, I go to your Twitter if there's a big game on because I'm like, oh, well, I know that Mike is gonna explain this to me because I don't know what all the hullabaloo's about. That's very kind of you to say. I often wonder who in the world is still reading my
而且妙趣横生，你还非常擅长剖析棒球数据。是的，我发现，如果有重大比赛，我会去看你的推特，因为我想，哦，好吧，我知道迈克会向我解释这个，因为我不知道这所有的骚动到底是关于什么的。你这么说太客气了。我经常想，世界上到底还有谁在读我的
Twitter because it is either in ridiculous arcane sports data or just screaming about something that a politician said. And it's like the Venn diagram for the two groups of people that want both of those things has to be tiny. So I'm glad to know that you two are still in the Venn diagram overlap of people who read my Twitter. I am. I don't understand your sports analysis. Not always, no. But I find it just sort of fascinating to watch your brain work.
推特，因为里面要么是荒谬晦涩的体育数据，要么就是对某个政客说的话大喊大叫。而这两种想要这两类内容的人群的维恩图（Venn diagram）交集肯定小得可怜。所以我很高兴得知你们俩依然在阅读我推特的人群的维恩图交集里。我是。我不懂你的体育分析。不总是懂，不。但我只是觉得看着你的大脑运转非常迷人。
Yes, and we love data. Jenna and I have discovered one of the things we have in common is we love tracking things. We get very excited. Just you name it. We track it on the show. Like I became obsessed about every plant that was at front reception and I would document how every week there was a new plant. And that's something that I find fascinating about baseball is there's so many different stats. I don't understand them, but I will go to your Twitter when there's a big game and people are talking about stats. Yes. Pitches. You really break down the pitches. Yeah. Well, part of what some people love about baseball and what some people hate about it is the amount of data that you can
是的，我们喜欢数据。詹娜和我发现我们共同点之一就是我们喜欢追踪各种事物。我们会感到非常兴奋。只要你能说出名字的。我们在节目里都会追踪它。比如我开始痴迷于前台接待处的每一株植物，我会记录每周是如何出现一株新植物的。这就是我对棒球感到着迷的地方，里面有太多不同的统计数据了。我不懂它们，但当有重大比赛、人们在谈论统计数据时，我会去你的推特看。是的。投球。你真的把投球剖析得很透彻。是的。好吧，人们喜欢棒球的一部分原因以及人们讨厌它的一部分原因，就是你可以
analyze. I love it because I'm the same way. I get nerdy about like, about numbers and stats and stuff. But again, like when I when I go to my Twitter account and post like 11 consecutive tweets about like whether a certain pitch was a ball or a strike, I do have the thought of like, who is this for? Like, who is reading this right now and enjoying it? But that's the joy of Twitter is you don't ever have to know. If you don't wanna know, you can just send it out in the university and who cares? Well, we have one final wrap up question for you. We always ask everyone who is on the show
分析的数据量。我喜欢它，因为我也是这样。我对数字和统计数据之类的事情有着书呆子般的狂热。但话说回来，当我跑到我的推特账号上连发11条推文，讨论某一次投球到底是坏球还是好球时，我确实会有这样的想法：这是写给谁看的？此时此刻究竟是谁在阅读并乐在其中？但这就是推特的乐趣所在，你永远不必知道。如果你不想知道，你大可把它发到宇宙里，谁在乎呢？好吧，我们为你准备了最后一个总结问题。我们总是问每一个上过节目的
or worked on the show, if they took anything from the set. Okay, so unlike probably many of the people that you've interviewed, I left in the middle. Right. I was around for the first four seasons and then the beginning of season five. And then Greg and I started developing parks and recreation together.
人或者为节目工作过的人，他们是否从片场拿走了什么东西。好吧，所以可能不像你采访过的许多人那样，我在中途离开了。对。我在前四季以及第五季初都在。然后格雷格和我开始一起开发《公园与游憩》（Parks and Recreation）。
I worked out of the offices. Like I was still around, but slowly over the course of season five, I receded into the background. So I didn't know, I think, sort of intellectually understand that I was leaving leaving. And so I didn't really think to grab anything specific from the set because it was like they were still being used. Right. Still making the show. So I really didn't take anything. I have a couple things that I do treasure
我在那些办公室里工作。就像我依然在周围，但在第五季的过程中，我慢慢退居幕后。所以我想我当时并没有在理智上意识到我正在离开、正在离开。所以我真的没有想过要从片场顺走什么具体的东西，因为感觉它们还在被使用。对。还在制作节目。所以我真的什么都没拿。我有几件我确实很珍视的东西，
that are related to the show. One of which was when I left, Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky went to Phil Shea, property master Phil Shea, and got his contact for who made the Dwight bobblehead that Angela had given to Dwight as a present. And they had a Mike bobblehead that Angela had given to Dwight as a present and they had a Mike bobblehead made. Oh,
它们与这部节目有关。其中之一就是当我离开时，李·艾森伯格（Lee Eisenberg）和吉恩·斯图普尼斯基（Gene Stupnitsky）去找了道具师菲尔·谢（Phil Shea），拿到了制作安吉拉作为礼物送给德怀特的那个德怀特摇头娃娃的厂商的联系方式。他们定制了一个迈克摇头娃娃，那是安吉拉送给德怀特的礼物，他们定制了一个迈克摇头娃娃。哦，
And as like it was sort of like a parting gift. And so I still have the Mike bobblehead. The only problem is I used to wear glass. I wear contacts now every day. But back then I wore glasses pretty often because we would often work until like, you know, one in the morning and my contacts would dry out and the bobble, the Mike bobblehead had glass had actual glasses on and at some point I think when we moved the glasses broke off, which is a bummer and
这就像是一个临别纪念品。所以我还留着这个迈克摇头娃娃。唯一的的问题是，我以前戴眼镜。我现在每天都戴隐形眼镜。但那时我经常戴眼镜，因为我们经常工作到凌晨一点左右，我的隐形眼镜会变干，而那个迈克摇头娃娃戴着眼镜，戴着真正的眼镜，然后在某个时候，我想当我们搬家时眼镜摔断了，这真是一件让人沮丧的事，
I've often thought about trying to repair them somehow and put them back on. So I have a mic bobblehead and I do have somewhere, and I don't even know where, there was a moment at which everyone realized that the world's best boss mug would be a thing that was going to matter for the run of the show and Phil ordered like 24 of them just as in case they broke or in case we needed more of them or whatever and I asked him if I could have one and he gave me one so I have a world's best boss mug not one that was ever used it's not a famous one it's not the one from the opening credits or anything but I do have a world's best boss mug, not one that was ever used, it's not a famous one, it's not the one from the opening credits or anything,
我经常考虑设法以某种方式修理它们并把它们安回去。所以我有一个迈克摇头娃娃，而且我确实在某处——我甚至不知道在哪儿——有这样一个时刻：大家意识到“世界最佳老板”马克杯将会成为贯穿全剧的一个重要道具，于是菲尔订购了大约24个，以防它们摔碎，或者以防我们需要更多之类的。我问他能不能给我一个，他给了我一个，所以我有一个“世界最佳老板”马克杯，不是用过的那个，不是什么著名的那个，也不是片头里出现的那种，
but I do have a world's best boss mug that is technically speaking from the set, I guess, if you wanna stretch the definition of from the set. And you know what else you have is you have your binder with all your notes, that is amazing to me. I have that, I have a lot of notebooks that I still look at from those early days. Yeah, and I'm sure there's a couple other things here and there somewhere. Someone, I think, after the finale, Wardrobe asked me if I wanted to keep any of the Mohs clothes.
但我确实有一个“世界最佳老板”马克杯，严格来说它是来自片场的，我想，如果你愿意对“来自片场”这个定义做点延伸的话。你知道你还有什么吗？你还有装满你笔记的那个文件夹，这对我来说太惊人了。我有那个，我有很多早期的笔记本，现在我还会看。是的，而且我确信这儿还有其他一些零零碎碎的东西。我想，大结局之后，服装组问我是否想保留任何莫斯（Mose）的衣服。
And I believe what I said was, please burn them in a fire. Oh my gosh, Mike, this was so fun. Thank you so much. Thank you for having me. It's so nice to see you too. I'm so pleased that you are the official voice of the show. It seems very fitting to me that the world is seeing the show through your eyes. That's very kind of you to say. We're loving it.
而我相信我当时说的是：请付之一炬吧。哦天哪，迈克，这太有趣了。非常感谢你。谢谢你们邀请我。见到你们也很高兴。我很高兴你是这部节目的官方声音。在我看来，世界通过你的眼睛来看待这部节目，这非常契合。你这么说太客气了。我们很喜欢。
That was amazing. I love talking to Mike. I could talk to him forever. Me too. And he said to us, you guys, he was like, if you ever have any questions for me about anything for the office or other things, let me know. And I was like, Jenna, how often can we text him? Exactly.
太棒了。我喜欢和迈克聊天。我可以跟他聊到天荒地老。我也是。他对我们说，伙计们，他说：如果你对办公室或其他事情有什么问题，随时告诉我。当时我就想，詹娜，我们能多久给他发一次短信？没错。
Exactly. Yes, Mike, get ready for an email flurry. You love the word flurry. It's cute. for an email flurry. You love the word flurry. It's cute. It's a flurry. I mean, instead of Jenna's blowing up your phone, she flurries up your phone. I'm going to flurry it. Well, you guys, Mike's book is called How to be Perfect, the correct answer to every
没错。是的，迈克，准备好迎接邮件狂潮吧。你很喜欢“狂潮”（flurry）这个词。这很可爱。迎接邮件狂潮。你很喜欢“狂潮”这个词。这很可爱。这就是一场狂潮。我的意思是，与其说是詹娜狂轰滥炸你的电话，不如说是她对你的电话发起了狂潮。我要发起狂潮了。好吧，伙计们，迈克的新书叫《如何做到完美：每个道德问题的正确答案》（How to be Perfect: The Correct Answer to Every
moral question. It is out now. And Mike really is giving away 100% of everything he's making on his book to five different charities and the book is awesome. Well that's our show this week guys. Thank you so much for listening to this episode of Office Ladies. Next week we have the promotion. Yeah, Jim gets a little mini office in the office.
Moral Question）。现已上市。迈克真的把这本书收入的100%全部捐给了五个不同的慈善机构，而且这本书棒极了。好吧，这就是我们这周的节目，伙计们。非常感谢大家收听本期“办公室女士”。下周我们要讲《晋升》（The Promotion）。是的，吉姆在办公室里得到了一个微型小办公室。
He gets a glass box. He does. In the middle of the bullpen. It's strange and interesting, and we'll tell you all about it. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey
他得到了一个玻璃盒子。他确实得到了。在开放式办公区的正中央。这既奇怪又有趣，我们会把一切都告诉你。下周见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是奥德赛（Odyssey）栏目，
and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由詹娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Bubbaco）。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》（Ruppertree）。本集暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。